this is Jocko podcast number 395 with
Carrie Helton and me Jocko willink good
evening Carrie good evening also join us
tonight Leif Babin good evening life
good to be here Echo still not here
still
I guess people getting worried look not
that they don't like Carrie Helton but
he's got that you know he's like the
people's Champion absolutely I like the
echo Charles Echo Charles man of the
people and so they're kind of wondering
where he's at don't worry everybody Echo
will be back he's he's on important
strenuous business right now important
important strenuous business right now
in Hawaii
in the meantime let me tell you this
the colonel expected the highest level
of discipline from his first of the
506th soldiers
he knew that slacking here even when
just going to the chow hall for lunch
could result in horrific wounds and
death
discipline in such a situation started
with the little things high and tight
haircuts a clean shave every day and
uniforms maintained
with that the more important things fell
into place body armor and helmets worn
Outdoors at all times and weapons
cleaned and ready for use at a moment's
notice
discipline created vigilance and
operational Readiness which translated
to high performance and success on the
battlefield
we sent task unit Bruiser seals from
Delta platoon to live and work out of
Camp Corregidor to train and combat
advise Iraqi soldiers there and support
the first the 506 Band of Brothers
when the seal element arrived they
humbly took on the same habits as their
first of the 506th hosts
despite more relaxed grooming standards
seals typically a joy elsewhere the
seals at Camp Corregidor cropped their
hair short shaved every day and even
donned the same ACU Army Combat Uniform
camouflage of their army counterparts
and that right there is a little excerpt
from a book
called Extreme ownership
which was written by Leif and me the
that is from chapter four check your ego
and
the reason we're pulling that quote
today is not to talk about ego well at
least not initially but more to talk
about culture inside of an organization
the first the 506
from the 101st Airborne is one of those
units in the military that has an
incredibly strong culture when we work
with them you could absolutely
recognize and feel the culture that they
have and
there are a lot of
military units that have a strong
culture inside of of their organization
and there's also civilian companies and
businesses that have strong cultures
inside of their organization I know that
in tasking a Bruiser we had a strong
culture inside of task and approves you
could say the same thing that we've got
at Echelon front
the Marine Corps
Carrie
yes sir how's the culture in the Marine
Corps report it is um one of the
strongest cultures I've I've ever
experienced I I agree I think that the
Marine Corps has
one of the strongest cultures in any
organization in the world
I know that's a bold statement but the
Marine Corps got a an extremely strong
culture
the Seal team culture
the SEAL Teams actually has a very
strong culture
some of it good
some of it not good you could say the
same thing about the Marine Corps as
well you could there's parts of any
culture that can be negative in the SEAL
Teams
we have some outstanding culture
and we also have some culture that's
that that hurts us
sometimes they're similar right
um
we don't have much Doctrine in the Seal
team the cultures that you can kind of
figure it out which is kind of good
because it makes you very flexible but
also
there's times when it'd be nice if you
had some Doctrine there's a there's a
culture in the SEAL Teams of bending
rules
would you say that's an accurate
statement life definitely accurate now
when you went through buds did you guys
say if you're not cheating you're not
trying
yes that's a pretty common thing and and
did did your instructors reinforce that
or did they
pull you back towards following the
rules
uh I mean if we're in like a Boku race
and uh you got busted cheating I mean
you paid the man for that certainly so I
think there there were folks
um who tried to push that certainly and
and
um
you know I I think uh I would say on my
instructors largely uh tried to try to
bash that out of us you know like hey if
you if you're cheating on this you're
not following the rules like we're gonna
drop the hammer on you here too and at
the same time you're only cheating
yourself yeah well we definitely got
told you're only cheating yourself the
thing is and I think I talked about this
with Ben Ben Milligan for sure
um for talking about from his book
buy water beneath the walls worst title
ever been it's awesome probably one of
the best it actually is the best
historical book about the SEAL Teams
but the title which I've been harassing
Ben and Ben about since I met him and I
actually harassed him about the title of
each and every chapter that he's got
which is long but what an incredible
writer and what incredible job he did on
that but that's one of those things
where you can see where the culture
comes from
and if you think about what your overall
strategic goal as a special operations
Warrior
is
we're going to figure out a way to cheat
against the enemy right like you you
want to be able to
sneak up on the enemy catch him when
he's not looking sucker punch him
deceive him in any way possible never
never fight fair right never fight fair
these are these are all attitudes that
make sense they're part of our culture
and you can see where if you're looking
if you're actually looking for guys that
have that kind of attitude
there's some you know your borderline
your borderline or you're brushing up
against a criminal mindset right which
is I'll break rules I don't care
and you kind of need some of that in a
seal platoon if you have if every single
person is a rule follower you're not
going to be you're not going to be able
to do your job
at the highest level because everyone's
going to look at it problem and they're
only going to solve that problem within
the rule set whatever that rule set
might be maybe it's just the doctrine
but there but if you have someone that
says hey when you follow these freaking
rules
which you you are gonna have in a
sealable platoon at least
at least three guys that are like why
would we do it like that let's do it
this way let's cut this corner let's
figure out how to do this let's trick
them let's deceive them they're gonna
cheat
so that's the type of thing where it's
really good for your culture that being
said when it if you if you have a guy
that now is supposed to be following the
rules of a city or a state and and he
decides look I don't have to follow the
rules I'm a special operations dude so
I'm looking how to how I can get her
away from these rules that culture needs
to be reined in and you need to really
kind of put some guard rails up around
your culture same thing with the Marine
Corps I mean can you imagine the Marine
Corps of World War II you're like hey we
want you to kill everybody
which is what they were doing you're
going into Iwo Jima what what are your
rules Kill Everybody
then the war ends and now all of a
sudden you're in Mainland Mainland Japan
and you're doing basically security
Force operations
which you know you can read about in
Eugene Sledge China Marine that's like
you gotta you gotta be able to just pull
that culture back from killing everyone
to being a diplomat a warrior diplomat
so things are good things are bad
the culture the culture what I'm saying
is actually is the culture will be
strong culture is strong and if you
don't have control over the culture it
can it can definitely cause problems
um
you know throughout the book about face
hackworth he he continually refers back
to this unit that he worked with early
in his um early in his career and he
says this and about face for the next
four years I learned my trade one year
with the Recon company of the tank
Battalion and the po valley and three
more with tree Trieste United States
troop Trust
the illustrious unit whose 5 000
hand-picked members Walter witchell
called quote the Chrome plated soldiers
of Europe end quote we worked hard
during those years long merciless days
of training repeating repeating
repeating until we got it right our
transformation into soldiers inspired
and monitored by those battle Savvy ncos
who well knew that discipline and
tactical proficiency on the battlefield
were direct results of discipline and
combat skills instilled on the parade
and training grounds at night it was
down on our hands and knees all of us
hand waxing the barracks floors until we
had enough money to chip in and buy a
buffer you could eat off those floors
just as you could almost be blinded by
the brass belt buckles and brown boots
that each of us wore polished every
night to a dazzling finish the only way
out of these activities was sick call
but rarely was it used as as an excuse
it took as much effort to see the doc
you had to strip your bed M you're
perfectly pressed close into a duffel
bag see the supply sergeant and then the
first sergeant not to mention the Lion's
Share of the month's pay you'd spend
having to re having clothes repressed
when you came back as it did to continue
on with the normal routine
punishment was meted out by a process
known as NCO Justice
and if I ever create another hardcore
band I might call it NCO Justice for
crimes such as a uniform of less than
starch Perfection a bed that didn't
bounce a quarter or even a mildly
insubordinate smirk the sentence could
the sentence could range from 50
push-ups to double Pine double timing
around the parade field holding a 9.5
pound M1 rifle over your head yelling
I'm a I'm a until you
collapsed
general of the army George Catlett
Marshall once said morale is a state of
mind it is that it is steadfastness and
courage and hope confidence and Zeal and
loyalty Esprit de corps and
determination
morale he said is staying power the
spirit which endures to the end the will
to win
these words could have been the motto of
the 15th tank and for that matter all of
trust a command that really did live 20
regular army years behind the times so
you can see when you've got a unit like
that
everybody I mean he was a private
soldier at the time you know hackworth
and he knew what he was doing he knew
what the standard was he knew how he was
supposed to act
that's a culture
and you get culture in the civilian
sector too
[Music]
um
Tesla What's the culture at Tesla dudes
are sleeping on the floor right like
you're you're working 22 hour days
remember when Elon Musk went bought
Twitter
and he got rid of what two-thirds of the
staff something like this two-thirds of
the staff later it might have even but
more money than three quarters I think
it was eighty percent okay yeah so he
was getting rid of people and then I
remember seeing a picture on Twitter
and he had like this Core group left and
it was two o'clock in the morning they
were grinding it out and he was
basically like yeah
the culture just changed
from and everyone the culture was
remember that video that floated around
some girl she was like did you know
workday at Twitter and it was like her
getting a cup of coffee then her sitting
in a lounger than her getting a massage
then her like it was just this whole day
of leisure basically and it was like oh
I have a meeting now and then in the
meeting they were you know uh laughing
and joking around and then it goes to
mosque in in two o'clock in the morning
and they're all freaking grinding and
eating like they're eating a midnight
pizza so they can work more
there's a culture shift the culture
shift can happen right and he did that
culture shift there with like a with
like a baseball bat
um
Tesla
SpaceX like that's the that's what you
hear about those places you're gonna get
if you want to go work there you're
gonna you're gonna get after it in a big
way that's the culture Apple you know
culture of innovation so
you end up with culture inside these
organizations and
the culture that you have is just so
so powerful the culture is going to be
stronger than the leader
over time
but it's the leader that can set that
culture in motion and yet and I've told
many companies and organizations this
who's responsible for culture inside of
an organization everybody
because if you have the E5 mafia they
can their culture can overpower the
culture of the boss the the middle
mid-level managers if they've got like a
strong culture within the mid-level
managers they can overpower the more
senior managers just their culture is
stronger
if it's good that can be great if their
culture is bad
it can it it's going to be a problem
so
you know we were just thinking about
um
what do we do with culture how do we set
culture how do we make it happen
how do you establish a good culture
because ultimately and this is this is
something we've been talking about at
Echelon front a lot is culture is the
ultimate form of decentralized command
and if somebody is part of a culture a
strong culture inside of an organization
they know what they need to do
they understand what the what the
mission is and what they understand
who they are
what they're doing how they're doing it
you understand all those things from
culture which is which is a pretty crazy
thing I wrote that down somewhere I
wrote this earlier I took a note culture
is who you are what you are what you do
and how you do it
I never thought of that before but I was
trying to think of like what
specifically is culture it's who you are
it's what you are it's what you do and
it's how you do it that's what culture
is it's those things right there again
this is a
my thought today maybe somebody will
expand on it maybe I'm wrong but it
seems like a pretty good pretty good
thing right this is who we are this is
what we do this is how we're doing it
that's a legit legit statement
um so let's talk about a little bit how
do you how do you
how do you establish culture and I think
the number one thing number one thing
out of the gate is set the example like
what example are you setting we just
talked about Elon Musk he's working at
two o'clock in the morning alongside his
people he's remember when he was some
there was something wrong I think at
Tesla or SpaceX and they were they had
pictures of him he's just sleeping in
his office on the floor
that's the culture that's the culture
that he set we're gonna work hard so
the culture that you set the way that
you act the example that you you fall
under is the way it's going to be so
when I got to team one
oh you're you want to know when that was
Carrie when was that oh that was
happening today so when I got to team
one I was a young kid to show up there
and
the culture was so uh strong at Seal
Team One
and it was a culture of sort of extreme
professionalism
now was it was it extreme
professionalism compared to the Marine
Corps no it was not was it extreme
professionalism compared to
the kind of compared to the regular Navy
it was like yeah we kind of were on
board or or could compete with the
professionalism of the regular Navy and
we certainly were more
more professional in our uniforms and
haircuts and all that stuff was than say
team five down the street or team three
down the street as well it was this was
a well-known thing
you saw that when you got there you saw
like all the senior people
all those all the Chiefs and the senior
Chiefs they all freaking look squared
away uh what was it like when you
checked into team five life what'd you
have going on there which was what 19
what was it 2000 and I checked into uh
still D5 in August 2003. yeah so you
yeah so the culture look there's still
some of the culture but
as as Admiral Richards explained when he
came on the podcast around 2000 they
started an initiative which made all the
teams pretty much
have the same Mission around the world
back in the day
the seat the teams all had their own
they were geographically assigned so
back in the day I was at Seal Team One
and our area of operations was southeast
Asia Nam now it was 1990 which you know
just didn't meant we were going to like
Thailand and uh Seal Team three was
Southwest Asia so they had the desert
and then Seal Team five was I guess
North
East Asia because they were the the cold
weather Korea guys
and you all had different assignments
and then you you
got to like stay at a Seal Team for a
long time like there was guys that were
at Seal Team one that had been there for
like 15 years 12 years it was it was no
big deal for a guy to be a team one for
for 10 years you just oh yeah I'm a team
one oh when did you get here like oh
1974. you're like hey that's awesome
then they made so so you had the teams
were
they were more separate
and because you could Homestead at a
team and those people that set the
examples were there for a long period of
time it the cultures that each one of
the teams was very different so but when
you got to team five 2003 so that only
happened in 2000 and then it it actually
started to fully take place in 2001. so
when you got to team five team five
still had the reputation of like Hey
we're laid back
where where Team guys we don't really
have to comply with yeah but by laid
back I think uh I mean they were team
five certainly had the reputation of uh
partying hard and and I mean work
working hard but certainly playing hard
um uh and maybe playing harder than the
other teams down the street uh
originally I had orders to Seal Team one
uh out of buds and uh or at least that
was what I was gonna get and because of
the rotation cycle they rejected you
exactly I didn't I didn't make the cut
no but the because the rotation cycle I
was going to jump right into a new
Commander tour yeah like I would have
missed I and I was already a lieutenant
so I would have missed having an
assistant platoon Commander to her
um under my belt which I didn't want to
do and luckily I had some some friends
that pulled some strings for me
um and and uh over team five they're
like yeah come on over here we'll get
you and we'll plug you know so they were
just starting their workup cycle so as I
showed up the first guys were coming
back from the Iraq War uh from Seal Team
five they're just getting bad and they
get back September of 2003.
um I turned over which you turned over
with yeah so that that was but there was
still very much there was it was stalog
one you know it was the uh definitely
like it still kind of had that
reputation even though that was sort of
it was sort of it was definitely
starting to uh dissipate a little bit
um but then you know I think certainly
there was some real pride in team five
of like hey we get after on the
battlefield but there was definitely a
reputation for uh
um yeah the the squared away haircuts
and uniforms it was the opposite of that
surgery a lot of visors and uh cut up
uniforms yeah however we can not look
military was uh one of my certainly the
case one of my uh
one of my best friends that I checked it
that went through buds with and then
checked into team one with and you know
who he is he's like just a complete um
just as just like a viking freaking
Warrior dude that if you could he's like
he's on the list if you're going to war
he's on the list like he's he's he's on
the list 100 and everybody knows like
he's just a Savage and we showed up
and we're going on our first run at Seal
Team One and he he came walking out with
a visor on and master chief Master Chief
faculty walks up to him and he's just
like if I ever see you with a visor
again I'm sending you to the fleet I
mean we just graduated bus bro no there
was no in brief it was like Hey we're
doing a whatever it was the Coronado run
it's like a seven mile run we roll out
their first big run with the T you know
now you're at a team and we're all fired
up and this this friend of mine rolls
out with that visor on the green faded
visor and master chief just walks over
to him and is like if I ever see you
with a visor again I'm sending you to
the fleet and I was like God okay so
there you go we also had this when you
when you're
it's weird how you like what you just
said you're at Team five and you're like
oh this is our thing and you get told
that and you're like okay that's that's
you take on that that culture almost
immediately like it it's you can watch
it happen like that happened with my
buddy and I was like okay cool visors
are lame visors are weak like that we
don't wear those that was part of it
there was also this
some of the older guys would say team
one it's not just a number it's an
attitude
and you'd be like yo one we're one you
know what next question of course we're
one number one that's us that's our
attitude we're number one
and you hear that and you're 19 years
old and you're like well obviously this
is what we're doing you know this is
what is happening so that example that
you see and when you're in a when you're
part of an organization
that's the number one thing you do
that's the number one thing you do to
start establishing culture is you have
to set the example
that you believe the culture should be
and you know this is this is what I saw
with
um when I got to team one and even what
you're saying like you got to team five
and it was like things are a little bit
loose we're gonna work really hard but
we're not you know getting dressed up we
don't have to do this dumb we're
not doing this chicken stuff we're
we're freaking badass Team guys okay
that's that's your attitude that's what
you're doing
so
certainly
um
setting the example is important you
gotta remember that people are watching
you
uh
establishing
Who You Are
and there's a couple different ways to
do that
you know one of them clearly is the is
the one of the many many many many
things I stole from from hackworth which
is naming giving your giving your team
a name and I I can't tell you how many
construction companies I've worked with
now and sales teams and they've taken
this and they've named their sales team
and they've named their their
construction shift like that's this is
very common and it freaking works
so hackworth in the Korean War he took
over foxtrot or Fox company change it to
fighter company he gets the Vietnam
Battalion Commander he takes over the
the Hopeless and changes it to the
hardcore
um that and then you know when I took
over task unit Bravo
which is a lame name but change it to
Bruiser and and it's funny because
that's not an official thing well it
wasn't an official thing but it sure is
official you know what I mean like you
can see it in you know when we talk to
the people that are still in the SEAL
Teams they they talk about it that's the
way it is that's what it was
pretty just established what's what's
funny about that I was uh I was just
reviewing my copy of about face which is
uh what you gave to me as tasking a
Bruiser you know when our separate ways
when we came back from ramadi and you
know in the fall 2006 and uh
you didn't like you just handed me a
copy of it and I had you I had you write
in it and uh it just says to snow from
jko in the end of the day he was like
January is January 2007. sure so but
what's awesome about that as I was
reading through that book
that's the first time that I I even I
realized like okay where this thing came
from you know is this this new identity
that that uh hackworth had given his
units you know with the fighter company
and the the hardcore over condos
um I I think it's and so at the time I
remember when where like we're task in a
Bruiser and and it was if you see how
lace voice changed when he said that he
just stepped up next level but you you
said that and we're like I mean when I
first heard that it was it was kind of
like it wasn't even it wasn't like a
people were like oh oh we're to ask you
to bring you know it was it instantly
you're like asking a Bruiser okay it
gave us an identity and uh and it was
something that just instantly we stood
apart from everybody else and uh I think
it's the genius of that it was something
that at the time like I didn't really
give it a lot of thought I was like okay
cool we're task and Bruiser like
whatever you know but then as it very
quickly became like we're freaking
tasking a loser like oh they're tasking
to offer saskia Charlie we're tasking a
Bruiser and you'd get like the skipper
would be like oh the Bruiser guys are
gonna come down like that they would say
those kind of things and you'd be like
yeah exactly the Bruiser guys are coming
down that's what's happening
I I just thought this going back to that
example thing real quick I remember
talking to General mukayama
and he's talking about how when
hackworth showed up and I was asking
like oh did did you guys know who he was
he's like yeah everybody knew who he was
and then he says yeah he walks in and
he's like high and tight
a high and tight haircut is uniform is
just impeccable he's got that look on
his face he's lean he's strong and you
could just tell
and you're like bro and this is
hackworth and the funny thing is like
you look at pictures of hackwords he's a
pretty slight dude you know but he just
presented himself in a way he set the
example he wasn't even in a battalion at
that time he was just setting that
example
well that was uh that was pretty you
followed that model pretty well man
because because when you you came over
being the Admiral said and so we had all
kind of formed up and been together for
a couple weeks you know and and you know
Seth Miller the deal particular matter
were good friends we've been through bud
together like you know we we uh we'd
known each other you know for for
several years at that point I was
excited to work with Seth but we got
long you know like our hair it wasn't
that our hair was like we had haircuts
but we did we definitely didn't have
shaved heads that's for sure and then
you know if you showed up with this like
it's just straight up ax murderer but
your uniform was immaculate
squirt you know your head was shaved and
you just like glared at everyone and
didn't really say anything and uh you
know and when we met you you're like I'm
Jocko like squeezed her hand you know
and and didn't say anything and it was
but it definitely set the tone right
away of like oh this guy scored away oh
this guy's got a shaved head this guy
has a squared away uniform and uh and
you never like hey this is what we're
gonna look like but you you certainly
brought that example in and then so when
it became task in a Bruiser it was
um it immediately it immediately gave us
like we're unique we're unique we're
different from everybody else we're
different and and certainly that can be
in a bad way you know if the culture
went that direction but for us it meant
like Hey we're gonna we're unique we're
special like oh we're it's it's too hard
for everybody else like we're good we're
tasking a Bruiser we're gonna work
harder we're gonna come in early we're
gonna stay late we're gonna make things
happen you know it's uh and it just
started to immediately establish that
culture and and you you live that I mean
it was
I just remember you totally standing out
from every we had a formation behind
Seal Team three so the whole team's
formed up it's the first time the team's
actually getting together people are
coming in you know from different units
and and it was I never I'd never seen
you before I I'd heard about you and we
certainly knew of your reputation but
you instantly looked different than
every other seal back there uh just with
a shaved head and squared away uniform
and I was like Jack I can tell you I was
when I was at Seal Team One
I put in for the Seminole Admiral
package and I didn't get picked up
and then the other there was a the first
class got picked up and
shortly after they got picked up they
went to OCS and then one of those
officers that was a seal on the East
Coast seal
he went to OCS and he came out to the
West Coast to team one so now I'm an E5
at team one and this Ensign shows up
from the from the semen animal program
and
I was looking at him going dude what is
going on with this guy's freaking
uniform he looked one he looked 100 100
Next Level squared away and I didn't I
didn't know what was happening but you
could you if you stood him same thing
like if you put him in the line with 10
other officers and you said which one of
these guys do you want to you know are
you going to put your trust in you'd be
look at him and go I think this guy over
here he looks freaking squared away
and then I went to officer candidate
school and that's where that's where he
learned to do that and the freaking
uniform inspections are so psycho down
there like you wear those shirt stay
things
and did you wear shirt stays yeah you
wear these shirt stay things and you
tuck everything in and you everything's
tight and you've it's ridiculous
damn you look freaking squared away
and and then so anyways that's where
that's where I definitely got at OCS and
you know you you went to you probably
got you know I guess you might have
gotten some uniform inspections and buds
but those aren't real uniform
inspections at least in my opinion we
are you you differing opinion well I
mean I had spent a lot of time having
uniform inspections through four years
well that's what I was gonna say you you
were you were you did four years at the
Naval Academy doing uniform inspections
but then you went to the fleet data
you're out there and your our uniforms
were Immaculate buds man I'm talking
like boot shine like totally pressed
like you know the the grease uniforms
yeah totally dialed um and and I passed
every single one of those and I got
hammered every single time because I was
the class at YCA of course one person
fails which they always do yeah
um and I still thought of a funny story
too when I when I took over platoon at
Seal Team seven
the the assistant platoon Commander so
he he was working for another guy now
he's working for me and you know we're
having like our first conversation
and he's a great dude but you know we
don't know each other so he's like hey
is there anything I you know we're like
wrapping up at the end of the at the end
of our first day working together and
he's like uh is there anything else I
need to do and I was like yeah go get a
haircut and he goes I I just got a
haircut and I said like mine
[Laughter]
so he said Roger that uh uh good times
what what I think what really stands out
to me though is like you know not only
did you
you demonstrated this through through
um by setting the standard yourself but
what has started for me and when it
started for zest Stone and I think for a
lot of us in tasking and Bruiser was was
what we thought was cool you know in the
SEAL Teams like like at silty five what
I thought was cool is the guys that like
yeah man that guy's kind of like hey
that guy's an awesome operator you know
and but yeah he might have got arrested
on the weekends but who cares like he's
a you know he's an awesome operator
that's what you you want to be and who
cares if his uniform's not squared away
and his hair is messed up like we kind
of take take pride in that and I think
what it started to do was
that the the professionalism of like oh
it's actually cool to be squared away
it's actually cool to have a squared
away looking uniform it's actually cool
to be the most squared away looking guy
in the entire formation and have your
head shaved and you stand out apart from
everybody else
um and so that started to kind of change
my mind uh of and I didn't even realize
it at the time you know because because
we're just meeting you for the first
time and just FYI everybody
this is not to say that you should not
be freaking the hardest operator that
you can possibly be by all means this
isn't like the because there's dudes
that are super admin freaking dorks
Garrison freaking Warriors right that
are super squared away but they suck as
being seals so that's not what we're
talking about at all no obviously what
it was was we're talking about both
we're talking about like hey we want to
be they're not mutually exclusive at all
we want and and I had I didn't see it
that way because it almost seemed cool
to make it mutually exclusive instead of
looking at it as like hey no we want to
be the most awesome badass operators we
can be on the battlefield and train
ourselves for the worst case scenario
and in Garrison we want to be squared
away we want to have shaved heads we'll
have you you know we want to we want to
we want to be professional and we want
to be as professional and square the
ways we can possibly be in both Arenas
yeah it's a it's a definitely a
different mindset but it's really easy
to see it's really easy to see the
difference and you take if you take
people that aren't focused on that and
look there's plenty of seals that are
freaking awesome but they just didn't
never focus on that no one ever told
them like hey I'm gonna send you to the
fleet if you wear a visor I got told
that or my buddy got told that it's like
so we were focused on that and then you
know
you start to just see it that way and if
you didn't get that you wouldn't ever
look at it it's just one of those things
if you're not paying attention to it
you're not paying attention to it so
it's not like some other seal at Team
three at the time was a bad person they
didn't even think about their uniform
they didn't think about it wasn't even a
thing they're like oh yeah I put my
boots on well it doesn't really matter
what they look like or they're just not
thinking about it at the time
but when you think about it and you know
it's not like we're competing against
the uniforms or the squared away
uniforms of the Marine Corps because
like they would win like you can't put
there's no seal platoon that could beat
a marine platoon in an inspection of any
kind like we just it's just not possible
but if you're even leaning in that
direction you could do pretty good
against the other sealf of Dunes because
that's just the bar's low the bar is
pretty low that's like when uh when
seals have to do some kind of close
order ceremonial drill they do whatever
they can to minimize it as much as
possible like hey okay everyone we're
gonna go out prior to and be standing in
formation where we need to be because if
we have to March out there it's going to
be a disaster so we'll always go out
there and stand for an extra half an
hour so that way we don't have to March
out there
um
so
there you go establish who you are the
other thing that I was going to say and
this is this is a there's a little bit
of risk involved here but
coming up with
some kind of values out of the gate
coming up with some kind of Mantra out
of the gate is something that you can do
and actually I wish I had this Stoner to
this when Stoner took over
uh the task unit and he didn't really I
I can't say and he would he would refuse
to say that he took over task in a
Bruiser because he's like we're not
tasking a Bruiser we're not because they
split up a bunch of the guys and he
really only had the remnants of tasking
Cruiser so he he just ended up taking
over a position of being in a task unit
but
he wrote out like this is what we're
doing
and he had it on his he had it pinned up
and I was like freaking legit
I quite frankly I think that my
personality conveyed all that that
he had written down like it just
conveyed it but when I saw that I was
like it's freaking squared away dude
nicely done he had the he had made
little letterhead you know stormy get
all crazy he'd made little little task
unit too because I think they had
changed the number system or something
task unit 2 you know uh
whatever values and focus and then it
said you know we're gonna do this we're
gonna do this we're gonna do this and it
was like we're gonna train harder than
anybody else it's like all the normal
stuff but he had written it out so it
made it perfectly clear so that is
something that you can do
the only risk of it is is
if you roll into somewhere and now
you're just from the top creating values
and imposing them on everybody
there's it's it's gonna have a better
it's gonna it's gonna gain more traction
if it evolves over time if it comes more
organically from the troops themselves
and even hackworth you know taking over
the 439th it was like we're gonna change
small things he he changed little things
at a time he didn't go and look here's
the way it's going to be now he's you
know he did say like okay anything you
can't freaking travel with in a rucksack
we're getting rid of it don't look what
the hell are you talking about that was
one step and eventually it's like yeah
we travel light you know so so you gotta
you gotta think about that you got to
think to the extent of which you do that
and I would say probably a good
compromise or a good move would be to
set out some sort of
minimum aspirational ideas like we're
gonna work hard like something that
people aren't really going to be able to
argue with without being super detailed
because even if I you know if I said all
right listen we're going to be we're
gonna look squared away in inspection
ready I can't imagine if I would if that
would have been my leading like idea
I wouldn't have liked me you know what I
mean when I was in E5 I'd have been like
what's this guy talking about dude we're
freaking seals we're operators like who
cares what we look like so but if it
would have said hey we're gonna work
hard
and we're gonna be exceptional at our
jobs you're like I can get on board with
that so I think if you're going to set
up some values like that out of the gate
or some kind of a mantra and the Mantra
is another thing the Mantra is something
that can come it's better off coming
organically
and so you end up with something like
BTF you know you end up with something
like Semper Fi
you end up with uh never quit you end up
with something that comes organically
btf's a good one like that was just Tony
just started saying it
but it became BTS yeah big tough frog
man meaning
it's not it's an adjective yeah this
guy's a big it's a noun this guy's a big
tub frog man it's a it's a verb we're
gonna BTF
it's a motivational chant you know
so but it just came organically but and
yet it answered so many questions it it
was part of the culture because the
culture is hey guys
should we do another immediate action
drill in the 120 degree Heat
or should we call it a day
we all know the answer that the answer
is BTF the answer is just we know what
we're doing it's BTF that's what we're
going to do
should we
should I say that I'm hot right now and
I and I and it's very sweaty
and I and I feel like it's too warm out
or should I just not say anything it's
like oh I'm going to BTF should when I'm
freezing cold say like hey guys I'm cold
um can I get in the Humvee and wait
until we hit the target before I go
outside or should I just BTF the answer
is you're just gonna be TF
but back to your you know your open
discussion about like if you're not
cheating you're not trying and how that
can become part of the culture I mean
that was very prevalent when I joined
the SEAL Teams like people were debating
about like you know the the the old
school years you know from the 90s of
like Hey we're gonna do the you know uh
uh we're gonna we're gonna drop you off
for the 14 you know kilometer Patrol in
like hey we roll open Vehicles now we
don't need to do that stuff anymore
um and there was a real there was an
attitude of some people in the teams
that like hey
we don't need to do that like hey you
know what hey we'll just we'll just uh
we'll just have a you know we'll just
virtually say we foot patrolled in and
you'll drop us off at this point here
and we'll we'll go hit in 500 yards
we'll go hit the so we'll cut down what
should be a two and a half kilometer
Patrol into you know the last 500 meters
or or a 10 and a half kilometers yeah
Patrol yeah and so and we weren't even
doing that kind of stuff just because of
the the largely Urban focused combat of
Iraq
um I don't think I ever did a 10 and a
half kilometer Patrol yeah but we were
doing two or three kilometer patrols and
over some rugged terrain certainly but
guys were cutting that down to where
they're like no no we're just gonna
we're just gonna on the X yeah we'll
just we'll just we'll just get dropped
off right there and and it was
I think for you know BTF answered that
to say like hey
um
you don't foresee a situation where we
might have the foot patrol and
ironically it was you know you you right
away were like there was no you know for
you for Tony like for the the culture in
the task and it was like
hey we're not gonna We're not gonna ask
for breaks why because we we may
actually have to foot patrol in and
ironically when we deployed to ramadi it
was so freaking dangerous to drive on
these roads I mean 80 percent of U.S
cash is being inflicted by IEDs or
roadside bombs so we would we would
drive to the nearest you know safest
roads we could get to like the nearest
combat Outpost and then we would full
Patrol into these areas because you
couldn't drive into them so so we did a
hell of a lot of foot patrolling all the
time and carrying a ton of weight on our
backs and if we hadn't done that um we
wouldn't have been prepared for it so
um and in fact even still I don't think
I was as prepared as I as as I should
have been because the first Patrol went
out with the Marines was uh just kicked
my ass on that Patrol trying to you know
carry the gear I needed in water and
ammo and stuff for 48 hours you know in
around firecracker Circle up there with
Lima Company three at Marines so I think
those but that that BTF Mantra you know
was like yeah we're not gonna we're not
looking to cut corner we're looking at
trading hard we're looking to push the
standards higher and that was part of
that unique identity of being being
tasking a Bruiser we're different than
everybody else we're not we we're going
to push the standards harder oh they
they wanted to get dropped up near the
target we don't we actually can we get
dropped off further away so that we we
could actually train ourselves and push
ourselves harder dude I went to a couple
debriefs with tradex so at the end of a
training block we would go to trade at
and trade out with debrief the skipper
and us on like performance and but
before that we would debrief trade it on
like how the training was and what you
know what could be better and what could
could be improved
and like I'd go in there and
unfortunately like
especially one of the other task units
would be like there when they say well
they'd give their feedback and it would
be like literally it would be
you know there's no there's no Wi-Fi
hotspot at the thing and we need better
like access to hydration you know after
our IAD drills and you know also we
thought it was a little bit too
strenuous to work late and then get our
mission taskings early in the morning
like they would unfortunately
legitimately give those feedback points
and they'd get to me and I'd be like it
was outstanding you know it would
everything that they complained about
they would maybe think I was going to
double down but I couldn't do that
because I didn't feel that way at all I
felt like yes work us until late we will
get up in early in the morning for
Mission tasking of course that's what
we're gonna do so uh what's the correct
answer the correct answer is good to go
we're freaking good to go you did that
from a detached position of like what
does that look like strategically what
does this look like strategically and I
think that that to me was you know when
I think about the culture of task in a
Bruiser
um you know even the appearance we were
talking about uniforms and being squared
away that to me is like
we took pride in you know seals take
pride in wearing whatever kind of crazy
uniforms you've talked about at a time
on the podcast here hey we're gonna wear
off the shelf camouflage and some guys
have Woodland tops and desert bottoms on
and I've always thought and the book in
the book Blood Meridian they talk about
the Comanches and the Comanches are out
just like killing and stealing and and
so Cormac McCarthy rest in peace
just just passed away never got to talk
to him but he's like describing them as
they're approaching and it just it
sounds like a seal platoon like people
are wearing like top hats and this guy's
wearing like a dress and this guy's
wearing like a vest and this guy's
wearing a cowboy hat and they just all
look freaking crazy and different and
when I when I whenever I read that I'd
be like that's basic tune right there
basically that's what you get you know
like I'm gonna wear jeans I'm gonna wear
a freaking whatever just just whatever
random I could have got a new Cabela's
you know uh Cami shirt and plus I got
some you know old Vietnam whatever and
they're just going down the list of what
random stuff they're wearing so yeah it
gets pretty wild and that's it and
that's we almost took we took pride in
that as long as we're able to go and
perform on the ax and you know
accomplish our mission like who cares in
fact you almost take pride in how crazy
you look so when you you approached us
in task in a Bruiser about like about
this issue and about like hey
should we try to look uniform and so in
the in in how that came about was like
when you first kind of brought the
subject up like hey you know let's let's
all try to look uniform
Seth filner I thought you were totally
insane but I was I was like this is
totally crazy you know we were new guys
at Wimbledon and you know under our belt
um you know as the platoon commanders no
but like there was massive pushback
inside the platoon like what do you mean
we have to I have to set up my op gear
that looks like everybody else and
Charlie platoon has to look like Del
what are you talking about this is
insane so we actually we came to you I
remember this conversation well in your
office this is like during the workup
cycle we came to you in your office uh
up there in the 173 headquarters with a
little task in office and and we're like
hey we both like had talked about it
like let's go set Jacob I mean it wasn't
uh it wasn't that we were gonna upset
you straight but like hey let's go let's
go just push back again obviously
there's some things that I'm rushing it
doesn't make sense we're getting a lot
of pushback so we think we're able to
take care of our team and so we walk in
there and talk to you about that and
you're you just asked us a question
you're like
how freaking cool would it be if we all
look like Stormtroopers if everybody
looks the same everyone looks exactly
the same and when you said that to me I
was I was like that would be freaking
cool yeah especially it's like hey you
know what the other task units look like
right yeah you know how they all look
all like a bunch of Comanches running
around yeah
imagine if we all are completely
uniformed we all look the same like
Stormtroopers
that was pretty much that'd be cool that
was pretty much how you said it and what
was it what was interesting to me there
is like in about a 30-second question
that you have and it wasn't you were
like demanding that we do that you
simply asked us the question which
allowed us to reveal the truth to
ourselves uh so Stoner and I left there
like this is freaking awesome we're all
gonna look the same it's gonna be
different from everybody and it it gave
us that unique culture and when we put
it out that way to the team
it wasn't like hey Jacobs you know
saying this it was like hey this is the
way how awesome is this going to be and
it was and people took and Ram with that
but it was it was outstanding yeah there
was also a
uh wanting to be able to PID and not
wanting to be mistaken as a mujahideen
fighter is a huge part of that as well
and also now that we're talking about
uniforms I remember uh I I think it was
Stoner that was wearing like one of
those like mujahideen scarfs what are
those things called
uh it were interacting called the kefia
but what what do we we call them a uh
Sherman yeah yeah yeah so we get out to
our desert training place and here comes
Stoner rolling up and he's got one of
those things on and I'm just like I'm
like oh are you Moosh and he's like no
and I go you wearing that scarf for
he just like took it off and was like
Chad he took it off and never worn again
and uh I think we all got the word on
that too because no one attaching to
bridge it wore those things but what was
what really stood out to me on that is
like it it made it cool like it made it
cool to be like hey we want to look all
the same because that's going to set us
apart from everybody else it's gonna
we're gonna look professional and uh and
it just like it was it was instantaneous
for us to to take that from like hey we
think it's cool to all look different
and to do different stuff and it'll look
like just a bunch of Renegades out there
that don't look military to like hey we
actually look military yeah hey we're
part of a gang
this is what we are so watch out this is
how we roll intestine Brewster now we
did take that to
an excessive level when we spray painted
Punisher skulls
on every single vehicle and uh who is
who the a general came out to to see us
was it was it I think it's General Brown
yeah I think it was him
and you you're like take this off no it
must have been earlier than General
Brown because General Brown came out
pretty late
uh I don't know who it was but to me it
was PID like it was PID you know this is
like not a good thing where you're
rolling around and you're advertising
like hey this is us here's our Mark
um it did look cool though it did it
looked really cool and there had been a
lot of time and effort on you know every
single like uh gun truck had the
punishers goes on so but then we just we
just put them on our uniforms yeah yeah
the stencil still came in handy we took
it off we took it off helmets and we
took it off the uh the Humvees yeah it's
freaking legit and you know that's one
of those things where
you know as I'm you
hey so it looks looks fine I'm not
worried about it you know what I mean
it's like it's one of those things where
do you where do you hold the line or
where do you let it slide and it's like
hey man we got a badass bunch of
Troopers here and this is actually a
uniform now so we're gonna roll with it
and it's also a lot harder to identify
like like a vehicle
it's pretty obvious what that is
um I think though the questions we get
from you know from from leaders and we
were just talking with a bunch of
leaders of the council about this you
know about how you set culture for the
team and um you know we had some uh some
leaders of uh some some fairly big
construction companies up there that
were talking about like Hey how do I get
my people to have their job sites
squared away you know or make sure they
all have safety gear or to make sure
that they're the the trucks are cleaned
out at the end of the day and I was
telling them about that we were using
this as an example of it you got to make
it cool you got to make it cool hey
think about what everybody else looked
like the question you just asked what
does everybody else look like you know
they've got stuff you know it's not
squared away they don't have you know
they don't all look uniform there's
trash later on the job site wouldn't it
be cool if how how badass would it be if
if you showed up on our job site and it
instantly looks different than everybody
else it instantly looks squared away it
instantly looks free like you're like
hey these guys are professional these
guys are freaking out awesome and I
think when you threw that out there it
just it creates that culture where you
don't have to go around and tell people
to square their uniforms away because
we're all doing it because hey you gotta
look like everybody else why because
it's important we gotta look
professional so that we can go out in
the battlefield and actually have an
impact close with and destroy the enemy
um and we're gonna do that all looking
like a bunch of Storm Troopers they all
look at the exact same that I can go out
there and have a huge impact so
um I think that's as Leaders trying to
set culture for the team you got to make
that we're unique we're special we got a
different identity we're going to
outperform everybody else and that
matters and if you make that something
cool that people are striving to do then
you've got a team of people that are
holding themselves accountable and you
got that like peer pressure to like get
squared away and get on board with the
standard so that everybody goes out and
kicks ass and outperforms the other
teams out there yeah the the gang
polices itself you know once you have
those standards set the gang polices
itself they don't let no no slack occur
um then when it comes to that you know
the the behavior of other people when
you're trying to establish culture
establishing culture that means you
reward
behavior that is within the culture and
you punish or at least mitigate Behavior
that's not within the culture so you
know you use carrots and sticks
basically and you know we prefer to use
carrots right we prefer when somebody
does something that's super squared away
that's what we prefer to focus on we
don't want to go like oh you're yeah you
need to wear a different uniform like
like you said I didn't really do that
but the E5 Mafia would tighten tighten
some fools up
that's for sure but
just carrots and sticks and so if you're
in an organization and someone does
something they you know you have a your
your the client the the customer's
always right great okay cool customers
always right well when one of those
cashiers goes out of his way to you know
take care of a customer that was having
an issue and they needed to help
carrying stuff for the car so they
locked up the register and went and
carried the stuff the car and took care
of the customer and whatever like then
you you reward that person
and you tell that story so people
understand that they will be rewarded
for these behaviors that support our
culture that we have and when someone
does something stupid
you look and and you got to be careful
about making the example out of people
and you don't necessarily have to name
them but if somebody does something that
doesn't support the culture then you
call that out as well and again am I
looking to call out individuals and make
them look like idiots no but to say Hey
you know this really negatively impacted
our company because we had a bad Yelp
review why do we get a bad Yelp review
because we treated a client we treated a
customer bad and here's what happened
and now we got to go and we've we're
gonna give that person you know a gift
certificate or whatever but why we why
are we doing that let's not let that
happen that's not what we do here that's
not who we are that's not what we do
that's not who we are that's not how we
do it you violated one of those right so
think about rewarding the positive
support to the culture and
punishing or mitigating or calling out
things that are not in support of the
culture I don't know if I mean I I'm
trying to think about like I don't
remember any like
I guess there were some punishments you
know meted out for folks that got in
trouble before we deployed and there was
some there were some uniform inspections
and things like that task and bruising
but that was minimal stuff and none of
that came from you it came from the you
know the ncos that were trying to hold
the line and it was uh
um but I think for me like there was a
lot of there it was a it was an
opportunity to educate people about why
this is important and how it's going to
impact us so like so not knowing do we
have to look squared away we actually
have to treat the soldiers and marines
that we engage with with professionalism
and respect and you know and if we don't
do that then we're actually going to
we're not going to actually go out and
be able to operate in the battle space
they're going to assume we're a
professional they don't want us here and
particularly we had so many examples of
Special Operations units that had
treated them unprofessionally and caused
some bad blood between you know
conventional Army and Marine units and
Special Operations units so we had to
overcome or actually digging ourselves
out of a hole
um and even just even walking up to a
senior officer or NCO and just treating
them professionally and talking to them
and addressing them by their Rank and
and you know uh it just that right away
like immediately set us apart and I
think you did a great job educating us
about why
about why that's important and how that
was going to impact our ability to go
out on the battlefield and conduct
operations and have an impact yeah it
might sound crazy so if you're a
civilian and you're listening to this
the way it works is you have Geographic
areas and the geographic areas
are controlled by conventional forces so
for instance the city of ramadi overall
was controlled by an army colonel and
then it was broken up into smaller
sectors that were controlled by either
Marine Corps Battalion commanders or
army battalion commanders and in those
sectors were broken up into smaller
pieces that were controlled by army or
Marine Corps company commanders they own
that real estate they they literally own
that real estate if you want to go into
their real estate you have to ask them
permission to go in you want to go to a
party at their house you've got to ask
them you can't just barge in there you
can't just go all on the seal I'm going
to go party in this house you can't do
that it's their house
it's their land so you have to actually
be invited or you have to ask permission
so if you act like an idiot or a jackass
or an arrogant person why would they let
you in there you're just going to cause
problems it's obvious but if you show up
and you're respectful and you treat them
with respect and you listen to what they
have to say and you you talk about and
explain to them how what you're going to
do at the party how you can help the
party
like hey I have the capability to set up
a DJ booth and play music for the party
we can help out here they're like oh
okay okay that sounds good you seem like
you you just don't go in there and start
kicking indoors and blasting music
doesn't work that way so yes we had to
build good relationships and yes
the your mom taught you
in fourth grade
that
you don't get a second chance to make a
first impression so what's the first
impression of a battalion Commander
that's been in the Army for 19 years
what is this what's the first impression
he gets from you
it's your uniform and it's your haircut
and it's your shave period end of story
period end of story you can't help that
you cannot help that even though they
might know that that stuff really
doesn't matter and they we've all been
taught this stuff we've all been taught
that no combat ready unit has ever
passed inspection and no inspection
ready unit has ever passed combat we all
know Murphy's laws we know those things
but there still is an inherent judgment
that's going to take place when you show
up and if you show up looking like a
jackass
you're going to get treated like a
so be professional and yes that's that's
what I explained the guys like hey we've
gotta we we've gotta show these guys
respect and I also distinctly remember
saying listen
this company Commander that you're about
to go talk to has probably been in Iraq
for 16 months right now he's a company
Commander this is his second tour in
Iraq and they're doing one-year tours in
the Army so that's who you're talking to
and by the way you know Lieutenant JG
how long have you how much time have you
spent in Iraq
um four days
how many times have you shot your weapon
zero so these guys have been in serious
combat for extended period of time and
treat them that way give them some
respect I remember talking to uh main
gun Mike baima who's the Bulldog comedy
Commander we worked super closely with
from uh bro he was the commander for
Bravo Company for uh 137 uh of the uh
ready first Brigade First Armor division
and uh I would say like I three
commented points to Iraq I think I spent
a total of about 17 months in Iraq uh
total and uh he he spent 37 months in
Iraq
well he had done I I want to say and you
can correct me if I'm wrong but his
first deployment to Iraq I want to say
was 14 months
and it was like you know 2000 it was
fighting 14 months straight then he went
home for a year took over company and
now he's back and he and he'd been there
already I think up in California or
something for already six months so he'd
already been in Iraq for 20 freaking
months in a leadership position the
whole time so and and then you talk
about the Battalion commanders you know
you talk about those company commanders
you know I remember going over to
Corregidor for the first time and I'm
meeting there the company commander of
gun gunfighter
and you know he's already like been
there for five months and he's lost a
dozen guys you know like these guys have
been in serious sustained combat
I mean I'm here to learn I'm here to
support we're here to help you what do
you how can we help you and it's it's
bizarre to think
that that might slip by you but
you know when you're in the single teams
you're kind of isolated you know you're
you're you're in a a little bit of a
vacuum in the SEAL Teams even my first
deployment was a little bit of a vacuum
where we're living on our own little
camp
we don't have to leave our camp for
anything we're basically going out and
conducting operations wherever we wanted
to all we would do is as I said earlier
check in with the battle Space Commander
we would leave go back it's just us
debriefing like you get then we go back
we do we come back to America we do a
workup by ourselves we do very little
interoperability with other military
units
and you just get a little bit isolated
so if you on your second deployment
and you roll to ramadi and you're like
kind of like I'm kind of a badass
you know I've done 38 direct action
missions it's like bro
think about what these other guys have
been through think about their
perspective there was a uh
there was a seal I worked with who uh
was rolling out with the Marine unit
um and kind of a latter part of
the Fallujah the Fallujah battle and uh
so he gets in the Humvee there's a
marine man of the 50 cal and he was like
it's like you know he was like have you
had space and time this thing like he
asked a question the other seals in the
vehicle were like yo Mandy
like you're you know we we got we got
like a we got like a 30-minute class on
how to headspace in time a 50 count like
you're asking a marine machine gunner if
he knows that headspace down vehicle day
12 of the battle of Fallujah that guy
has done that thing 10 000 times like
he'll know more about that weapon than
you ever can even imagine it's it was uh
he can head space and time it with his
pinky exactly yeah it was uh it was not
a good look for this little deal that's
a bar but the folks around him I think
uh administered some some corrections
but you know the back to the culture
stuff though I I want to make clear man
like you know we wrote an extreme
ownership chapter two like it's not what
you preach it's one it's what you
tolerate so certainly if people aren't
performing you know holding the standard
or performing the way they should
um or or uh then then yeah you gotta you
gotta oh you gotta hold them account we
gotta make an example out of them but
you never it wasn't it wasn't like a you
know this wasn't like you beating us
down and saying like we need to be
squared away it's you actually told took
extreme ownership of explaining hey I
gotta explain to you why this is
important and I think for the leaders
that are listening to this when you want
to build a culture of a high performance
winning team you don't go beat people
down if they're not their job site isn't
squared away or they're not looking
they're not as professional as they
should be on a call with a client you
actually need to take that as an
opportunity to you know holding them
accountable doesn't mean you just smash
them over the head
it means that you take ownership of not
explaining why this is important so they
understand how it's going to help them
if they if they they fall short of those
standards it's going to hurt the mission
and it's ultimately going to hurt them
you know and back to the construction
you know site example where you know
we're talking to leaders they're like
well obviously if our job site doesn't
look good that's going to affect our
ability to you know uh to uh to win
other bids you know for the for the for
the next next job but the front line
Troopers don't they don't see that the
guys they're out there work they don't
see that so you as a leader have to take
ownership of educating them of training
them of helping them see why this is
important how it not only helps the
overall mission but connecting that
threat of why back down to them and how
it's going to create more opportunities
for them to win the next bit if you have
a squared away looking job site so I
think that's just an important point to
make is this isn't beating people down
and I was never like oh if we don't do
this job who's going to yell at us there
was you never yelled at us yeah it was
you explained why it was important and
then you didn't have to explain to
anybody else because I was explaining
why it was important to my team and
they're explaining to each other some
new guy shows up that plugs in as a
augmentee we're letting them know like
hey man your uniforms look like
everybody else's here's how you set your
gear up yeah so explaining the why
Always critical
and then it's also an alignment check
because if I say to Leif Babin and Seth
Stone
hey we want to look squared away the
reason why we want to look squared away
is because the Army in the Marine Corps
owns the battle space and we want to do
a lot of operations in their battle
space therefore we need their respect
and trust and the first impression that
we give them is our uniforms
do you guys want to conduct a bunch of
combat operations
the answer is 100 yes so as long as
we're aligned you're like oh this is
going to get us to conduct operations
cool we're in that's all that's all it
is if I don't have a y then all of a
sudden you're like well why are we doing
this well because it looks better that's
not a reason or because I said so that's
not a reason or because you know even if
I refer back to Doctrine which in this
case is because that's the military
uniform even if I do that that's not an
answer that's not a why you know because
the book says so is not an answer
because I outrank you is not an answer
because
this is the way I've always done it is
not an answer none of those are answers
the why actually has to be a valid
reason
and then it makes sense and then you
then they don't have to worry about it
anymore I don't have to worry about it
anymore because you got it you
understand we're aligned we want to go
kill bad guys this is going to help us
go kill bad guys period in the story
that that whole thing I've talked about
the trump card you you have that trump
card of alignment it's like the trump
card of alignment
do you not want to do missions because
if you look like a jackass you're not
going to do missions no I definitely
want to do missions cool don't look like
a jackass make sense yes
there you go
another thing for culture is
history like
making sure people understand who you
are
where you came from right the who you
are part also entails where you came
from look
it was amazing to me that
the other military units the 137 you
walk into the 137 this is their
temporary tactical operations center in
ramadi Iraq it's a freaking crappy old
dusty blown out building that they
squared away and you walk in there and
they've got their they've got articles
hanging on the wall from World War II
that they went on deployment with to
show
what they did as a battalion in World
War II
same thing with the first the 506. the
three eight Marines they are saying this
is the battle streamers are there in
combat with them
that is a source of Pride it's a source
of history and yes it is a source of
culture
it allows you to see where you came from
if you know where you came from this is
like when people look up their uh 23 and
me you ever seen that thing where the
dude like looks at his readout and he's
got .002 percent
you know Nordic Viking and then they
just show him in his front yard he's got
a Broad Sword and a Viking helmet like
yeah
that's it's it's actually the point is
you can take that thing where you came
from and you can transfer it into how
you're going to behave right now
so when you know about these things like
you know when I got to Seal Team One you
walk into Seal Team One the quarter deck
back in the day Medal of Honor
recipients there's Mikey Thornton up yup
that's that's the goal that's that
that's the that's the model that's what
I'm gonna be that's what I'm gonna try
and be I'm not going to be that because
I'm not definitely not gonna be that but
I'm gonna try I know what the example is
the example is you risk your life for
your freaking teammate even when people
are telling you he's dead you still do
everything you can
that's the example
so that's the culture that's the seal
that's part of the seal culture
is you don't let your teammate down
Mike Thornton that's the story Mike
Thornton the his Vietnamese seals come
back to him and say the lieutenant is
dead
he's dead we need to leave and Mike
Thornton says negative I'm going to go
get him and saves his life so what
better example of you don't leave your
teammate behind there you go that's it
that's the culture so when you have a
company when you have a business where'd
you come from
who started the company
why did they start it what did they
overcome did they make it through the
depression did they make it through you
know what's interesting is nowadays we
talk to companies that made it through
2007 2008 the economic downturn they
went through a war for them
and they made it and that's part of
their history I worked with a company in
Austria that was five over 500 years old
they work with metal
now but back in the day they made they
made armor they made suits of armor and
now they make chains and cables but
they've been in business for over 500
years
there's some pride there right like
you're doing something so if you want to
establish a strong culture
then you need to figure out what's your
history is and you don't need to be
you don't need to be like this this
ancient company that's a cool example of
someone that's been around for 500 years
but it's also a cool example of someone
that's formed in 2003 and they made it
through the economic downturn and they
kept people on board and they had to
scrap and they had to take pay cuts and
they had to furlough people but they
made it that's part of the history it's
part of the story tell people so they
know where they came from if you know
where you come from it's an indication
of how you should be acting
you always talk about propagate the
story and and uh I think it's a super
powerful concept and uh I always you
know when I was teaching the junior
officer training course you know when we
got back from ramadi I went to the uh to
run that course for two years every
single seal officer graduated from our
training pipeline
um the mandatory reading uh for for all
those those officers was uh was
basilovax udtco operations in Vietnam
um and then uh the naked warriors about
the the underwater demolition teams in
uh in World War II and I think they're
that to me was like just giving you know
and now obviously you could add buy
water beneath the walls which is a
fantastic
um uh book that captures so much of our
history I always felt like one if people
understand that they realize it's not
it's not just about them it's about this
Legacy and Heritage that we've inherited
so if you go out and get drunk on the
weekends and you know or uh and and
arrested and give the SEAL Teams a bad
name it's not just about you or your
platoon or the current Seal Team you're
part of but the entire Legacy that
you're a part of it I think it also
you know it also uh just gives you like
there's been so many uh incredible seals
that that contributed to this Legacy and
uh particularly by water beneath the
wall some of those things that uh you
know I've talked to Vietnam steel
friends of mine that were blown away by
some of the history they didn't even
know about it that they read in that
book
um and when you realize like these guys
just you know went into China and
figured out like hey how can we what can
we do to actually go and attack the
Japanese and and uh offer a solution
here to go and and close with and
destroy the enemy and
um you know create this indigenous Army
running around I mean all just some of
those operations uh I always found that
to just to be a a fascinating way of of
giving people not only pride in their in
their Heritage and where they came from
but then how can I actually contribute
to this and then how can I make sure
that I could yeah I I don't tarnish that
Legacy the things that I do you know
could contribute negatively and impact
our you know our heritage 100 I mean
I've talked to Young seals and you know
I'll see young seals at let's say on
Memorial Day see those guys young seals
up it up at Mikey's grave up at Mark's
grave up at Seth's grave you know and
I'll talk to him and and say hey you
represent these guys now like I don't
I'm retired no one cares about me you
you guys represent these guys that
sacrificed their lives for their
teammates
you represent them now
so what you do reflects on them they're
not here to they're not here to do
anything else they made their sacrifice
and now it's on you so represent them
well
that's absolutely true absolutely true
um and yes propagating the story is
propagating this making sure you
remember that history and then when
things occur
and you're inside of an organization
it's it's sort of like what I was saying
earlier about rewarding but not just
reward but how do you capture that
information and let people know what
you're doing inside the organization
because cultures cultures were internal
right and look culture will bleed over
and and people on the outside of the
organization will see and they'll
appreciate hopefully if you develop a
good culture they will understand the
culture inside of your organization but
the focus for culture is inside the
organization so propagating the story
and making sure that people inside the
organization understand
what we're create we're writing that
history right now you're if you're part
of this team you're part of the history
of this organization if you're at
Echelon front right now you're part of
the creation of the history of echelon
front right now so what you do matters
and what you do is going to leave a mark
and when you do something when you get
this client and you turn them around and
they start they start outperforming
anything that they've done in the past
that's part of the history of the
company you did that that's you you're
part of it so propagating that story is
absolutely important I was just thinking
about this in the context of you know
tasking a Bruiser in our operations
ramadi and you know for so long in uh
particularly in the Iraq War right it
was it was seals and other Special
Operations units going out at night time
doing these capture kill Missions at
night time coming back before the sun
was up and so that became like oh that's
the Special Operations Mission and uh
and so we got some criticisms for going
out and being out in the daytime because
that's when the that's when the enemy
was actually moving around that's when
we were able to to engage them that's
when we can Engage The Local pop
fabulous you know as well and that's we
we've we we found that we could have the
most impact on the battlefield we'd go
in at nighttime set up the sniper
overwatches but remain over day when the
enemy was actually moving around and had
thought they had freedom of movement
um and so that's when we could do the
most damage to them and have the most
impact and it was interesting to me as
you know as we received some of those
criticisms because we were doing
something that was different from what a
lot of the other Special Operations
units were doing
it was very similar to underwater
demolition teams in World War II where
they were doing these nighttime
reconnaissance Beach reconnaissance uh
and then I Draper Kaufman I think was
one of the you know the father of the
underwater demolition teams he came from
the schoolhouse uh and I think it was
was it Saipan maybe it was his first uh
I think it might have been his first
operations in in uh in in the Pacific as
he left the schoolhouse to go out there
um it was either Guam or Saipan I I
don't remember I believe it was Saipan
but these huge operations you know to
take these these Japanese held Islands
back and and they're doing it in the
daytime and he was like this is crazy
like how can we do this in the daytime
you're going to get killed and then the
the seals that are the or the under the
Frog man the underwater demolition team
uh that had been conducting this realize
like hey we can go out and we can do
this in the daytime they almost almost
no casualties uh as a result of swimming
off the beaches it was minimal but they
were able to do a much better job of the
reconnaissance and come back and then
interestingly enough in Vietnam it was
the opposite so you didn't go out at
night time Charlie owned the night and
uh and so you didn't go out at night
time because Vietcong we're going to
Ambush you and kill you and so U.S
forces would just uh kind of hunker down
you know overnight uh in their defensive
perimeters well seals figured out you
know we're going pretty early in the war
like hey we can go out at night time and
actually have some impact
um and so so that seemed crazy to a lot
of people but it was it was part of I
felt like we were part of that Legacy
and tasking and Bruiser of like hey
where can we have the most impact on the
battlefield where could you know where
can we contribute most to the mission
we were certainly take are we taking
some more risk to be out of the dates
I'm sure but there's ways of mitigating
that risk
um which is exactly what we did just as
the just as the Frog man did and just as
the seals in Vietnam did yeah and and I
look at that oh as as my fault and this
is when we talk about propagating the
story
I didn't do a good enough job of
explaining broadly what we were doing
but more important why we were doing it
because you know when when we got back
and I actually would sit down with
someone to be like dude why are you
going on the daytime and say oh here's
the reasons and you go oh well we had to
work with Iraqi troops Iraqi troops
didn't have night vision Iraqi troops
had one flashlight per four guys and
we'd give them more but even that wasn't
really sufficient they didn't know how
to use that one flashlight yeah the
enemy was only out the enemy didn't come
out during the night at all which means
you could go out walk around all you
want but you're not going to have any
impact because there's nothing there and
once I kind of EX oh and the the
conventional force that we were working
with they had to push out and they had
to control areas and you have to control
areas not just during the night you have
to control them during the day too
that's why we did and guys we go oh okay
yeah that makes sense I didn't do a good
job while we were on deployment or even
when we got back of explaining what was
going on
what we were doing and most important
why we were doing it I should have done
a better job of that and then some of
some of the folks would have gone oh
okay I get it and there was a couple
times like I had one friend that was in
Baghdad and he emailed me like dude what
are you guys doing and I emailed him
back like hey bro let me explain it to
you I should that should have been an
indicator to me
but I I didn't you know I didn't catch
on that oh some people might be saying
what the hell are you doing and again
too bad I wouldn't have read uh Ben
Milligan's book because I probably if he
had written it faster or I guess he
couldn't read it at the time but if if
that kind of book with that kind of
information would have been around I
would have known okay I gotta propagate
this story a little bit better I got to
do a better job of explaining what's
going on
because otherwise people look at it from
a distance and they go oh that doesn't
make any sense like you said just like
they said to the the the frogmen and
just like they said the seals in Vietnam
like what are you doing going out at
night Charlie owns a night no we own the
night and we owned the day in ramadi as
well like we owned it
um so yeah those are good points
language
the language that you use creates a
culture
I'm gonna go to uh a little bit more
about face right now
here we go the men of the fourth 39th
had no unit identity and no pride in
themselves as a first step toward
rectifying this I decided to call my
hard luck Battalion the hardcore and the
troops recandos
the latter being part the latter being
the nickname of the first brigade ninth
division of which the 439th was apart
just as I had in three in the 3-3 at
Fort Lewis I insisted on a Airborne all
the way greeting between 439 soldiers
and their officers
so when he was at the 3-3 in Fort Lewis
he would the the the enlisted guys would
say airborne and the officer would say
all the way
uh when a soldier but in the 439 when a
soldier saluted an officer he said
hardcore a condo sir and when the
officer responded it was with a
heartfelt no Slack
at first my cynical hippie troop
sniggered over what they considered GI
Joe but it didn't matter I knew
the time would come when it would mean
one hell of a lot to each and every one
of them
so
the language that you use starts to form
your culture the BTF is a great example
all Navy all the time remember saying
that I do I've had and I always always
have this stuff in my platoons like we
down platoons and we'd have these things
that we'd start to say and it would
become part of the part of the language
right and tight like I was in a platoon
at Team two we said right and tight 47
times a paragraph you know get your
right in tight boy hey get is that the
right and tight over there like we just
said it all the time and guess what when
you're saying right and tight all the
time
that is what you start to behave like
when you say like like already explained
about BTF that's what we're doing are we
complaining no we're btfic are we taking
the easy Road no we're btfing are we
going to be soft no we're going to BTF
that's what we're doing so
the the idea that the language that you
use is going to also formulate your
culture
is absolutely true I remember at um
first the 506th like at the end of the
meeting the Battalion Commander would
say you'd say Curry and they'd all go
stands alone like that was everything
and you're like dude this is awesome but
just like he says he's he's admitting
hackworth is admitting like in the
beginning I knew these guys were like
this is freaking but after a
little while
you're like no slack that
becomes part of the way you function and
operate
that becomes part of the way you
function and operate
so the language that you choose to use
and the language that you choose to
propagate inside your organization
it becomes the way you operate at
Echelon front
relationships are Paramount everybody
says that relationships are Paramount
what does that mean that means
relationships are Paramount that means
if you're interacting with somebody and
there's something straining the
relationship you're going to prioritize
the relationship that's what we're doing
that's how we operate that's what we're
doing it becomes part of the culture so
think about the language that you use
inside your organization
I think it has massive impact it's
massive impacted you know as I read that
statement
um for the first time in that copy of
about face that you gave me and you know
January 2007 it uh it really stood out
to me because it's very much my
experience in tasking a Bruiser you know
I'm sure there are people that are like
oh that kind of rolled out no no there
was definitely haters and friends like I
friends of mine at Team three that were
in other to ask you to be like bro
what's up with you freaking guys dude I
was like hey bro you know we're just
btfing what can I tell you they were
like like make making fun of us jabbing
at us and at the same time kind of being
like damn that's kind of cool
for sure for sure and I think that
what's interesting though is I think a
lot of the guys who might be
there there was some complaining going
on hey we're you know why are we working
so much harder than everybody else I I
didn't you know we're going in earlier
we're staying later even when the
instructors had said like hey you guys
are good to go I mean I remember
multiple times we were like hey
you you would just ask a question like
hey do you think we're ready for the
worst case scenario on the battlefield
and we look at each other and be like
let's do another run you know and and we
do that where other other task units
we're not doing that and so that hadn't
been people's experience previously and
so there were some complaining about
that initially going on I don't get
enough sleep we don't get to go out of
town or you know we don't get do all
these other things that they they wanted
to do and the other task is they're
doing them but the moment that like the
moment that we started outperforming
everybody you know as as that
outperformance became very apparent and
those other guys were kind of looking in
like hey what are these guys doing over
here and the the training you know
Detachment instructors are like
dang man you guys are the best tasking
and I've seen come through here you know
those when we started to hear that kind
of stuff those complacious those
complaints went away pretty quickly
because people took pride in being a
part of a a unique unit that was able to
outperform you know uh everybody else
like Hey we're Bruiser we do things
different we do things better and and
that translated directly on the
battlefield
I mean that turned the turnover that we
got of like hey don't go into these
areas of ramadi because you're all going
to get killed you know and we're we're
looking at how can we get in there how
can we actually get in these areas yeah
we don't all want to get killed we're
gonna have to take some we're gonna we
we took tremendous steps that we could
and to mitigate the risk to our our
forces but if we knew that if we went
into some of these areas that nobody
else could get into uh that we could
actually have some massive impact on the
battlefield
um and and and so we took pride in being
able to go places that other people
couldn't go yeah
yeah two things number one
this is our perspective
right and and here's why I want to point
this out you can hear what we're saying
you can hear Leif saying like dude we
were tasking a Bruiser we were better
we were working harder that's our
perspective
look were the other tasks working hard
hell yeah they were they were freaking
getting after it and let's say they were
working harder than us
which they weren't but let's say they
were let's say they were let's say they
worked there were some other other
freaking outstanding freaking dudes in
those other tasks units 100 no doubt
just freaking outstanding guys
even if they were working harder than us
guess what we thought we were working
harder like we were inside our world we
had a strong level of confidence that we
were out working and outperforming
everybody else
so that's a positive thing what are we
gonna watch out for and what did we
watch out for freaking arrogance all the
time like letting letting that task unit
Bruiser thing become a hey we're better
than you
is is what you have to watch out for
because if we're better than Yoon and I
think I'm better than you that means I
didn't have to work as hard as you that
means I don't have to train as hard as
you that means we don't need to plan as
much as as you that means we can just we
can just make things happen because
we're your Bruiser no it's not like that
it's actually the opposite of that it's
we're tasking at Bruiser which means we
have to work harder which means we have
to prepare more which means we have to
plan more which means we have to do
extra runs it's because we're tasking a
Bruiser that we have to do more it's not
the opposite so be careful and you know
we were talking about this
and I've actually used this I've been
talking about about this a bunch now
this this idea of being in stressful
situations and how you prepare for
performance and how you got to prepare
you plan you rehearse you visualize you
for you you don't worry about things
that you can't control and ultimately at
the moment just before the moment of
execution you have to get a little bit
cocky you have to get a little bit cocky
and that's the way that I operate that's
why I've always operated as humble as I
can possibly be until I put my night
vision goggles on until I Lock and Load
my weapon then watch out cause I'm a bad
and I'm coming to get you
and you're not gonna be able to do
anything to me that's what's happening
or like Jiu Jitsu like I'm training my
ass off I'm training my ass off when we
when you look at me like hey let's roll
and we clap hands all sudden I'm Gonna
Get You Like that's what's happening
I'm not nervous I'm not scared like oh
what's gonna happen so so having that
humility that then you can lean into all
right it's go time and now we're
confident and that's what you're doing
you know we used to do that with
Fighters like you get that fighter
you're getting ready getting them ready
for a fight
they're getting their ass kicked in the
beginning of training camp you're you're
making sure they're getting their ass
kicked you're making sure you're
bringing in fresh people they're kicking
out they're getting their ass kicked
they can't get up they can't get off the
ground their striking sucks they're
behind and then as you get closer and
closer they're doing better and better
by the time you're a week out
they're kicking your ass whether you
whether they can or not honestly and I'm
not trying to look I'm out of the
business now I'm not training Fighters
anymore but you don't want to kick a
guy's ass
three days before he gets into the cage
against a world-class dude because his
confidence not going to be there so
you're gonna you're gonna let them build
that confidence back up just like a dog
you know a working dog when you have a
working dog an attack dog an attack dog
never loses a fight in training they
never lose a fight they don't even
understand what that means when that
freaking Ben Belgian malmour comes at
you it is when it's coming to get you it
has never lost a fight before ever
it's coming it knows 100 in its mind it
can win
when you come to my house and I have
Odin my German Shepherd that weighs 120
pounds he's never lost a fight before
he's never had a bite that didn't take
someone down and stop them he doesn't
understand you have a gun a loud gun
he's been through that where that's not
going to stop him he's heard that loud
bang before it's not going to stop him
so what you have to do is you have to be
prepared to die because these animals
they've never lost
so as you're going through that mental
cultural formation you want to have them
humble you want to have them work but
then you also want to teach them hey
look we we win that's what we do clutch
time we win what happens when a what
happens when a player or an individual
gets the reputation of like they're a
go-to guy in the clutch scenario Michael
Jordan
he's oh who are you going to give the
ball to you give it to Jordan
when he's feeling good what are his
chances they go up astronomically when
he's feeling bad or if he missed a
couple shots now his game is off like I
mean Jordan's the wrong person to say
this about because what Jordan does is
ah I blew that one but watch this he'll
refocus he learned how to do that to go
oh I blew a shot cool watch this we used
to see this you know you see somebody
shooting head plates right you go
standard drill you got to shoot six head
plates you're going against me against
life so beep the the the the the timer
goes I pull out my weapon crack one
crack two I miss a shot
I've been shooting head plates all day
and I've been shooting head plates for
15 years
I miss a shot oh damn I missed it oh no
life's gonna beat me up miss another one
miss another one miss another one
when you miss a shot you got to just be
like whatever I meant to do that crack
so getting your culture to have that
nice level of humility all the time but
then also being able to flip the switch
and be able to execute as a team
extremely important extremely important
you actually want to have you can
actually work with a team
where you know like uh
starting up the vehicles
there's something about that I always
found when we'd say
uh starting vehicles in three two one
start them up and all the Humvees would
start at the same time you knew at that
moment in time you were an in-sync
organization that was about to go just
do whatever we got to do to win because
it everything everything fall you've
been running around you got planning
you're doing this you're looking for
your radio but all the stuff is going on
and then you get in the vehicles
everyone's loaded up Mount up Mount up
Mount up
in three two one start them up
and it's like a mental thing that's
going on and everybody feels it
so think about what you can do with your
team where you can activate their
confidence
where you can tell them it's go time you
get done with a brief and what's the
last thing you say to them that's going
to get them in that mode where they're
going to overcome that's what we do
I I think those things are directly
related and I'm getting fired up you're
talking about starting the Hobbies I
mean it's just that there's nothing like
when you've got a uniform group and
everybody's in sync
um you know and we talk about the
dichotomy right of balancing confident
but but not cocky you got to be
confident but you can't be cocky and so
when you're talking about uh a whole you
know like never getting arrogant and
thinking like oh we're the best
um I I actually I think that what gives
you the confidence to go and execute
when it's go time on a combat operation
and I've never you know I've never
fought a UFC or been a bit of
professional MMA fighter but I gotta
imagine it's a similar deal is is that
you have put in the work you you've
challenged yourself you know and I think
what made us good at task in a Bruiser
was that that we were we would critique
ourselves harder than anybody else and
right you know when when I was used to
the the training instructors really
picking us apart you know going through
the work up cycle of like yeah you need
to fix this you need to fix this you
screw that up they didn't they didn't
have a lot to say when we were done
debriefing ourselves because you know
for the most part because we were just
eviscerate ourselves about all the
things that we actually needed to work
on and and so that was that enabled us
to push the standard we're always
looking to get better in everything that
we did and because you know that's why
we talk about humility is the most
important quantity leader constantly
scrutinate scrutinizing ourselves about
like hey are we actually ready for this
worst case scenario can we actually get
better can we improve and because we
pushed ourselves that hard and and
because we were humble and because we we
put in the extra time and the extra work
and the extra preparation it gave us the
confidence to go and execute
um in a way that that I think those are
directly related so you know one of the
things that really stands out to me is I
mentioned earlier like the training
instructor said you guys are the best
task unit I've seen come through here
and so you know when you get assigned a
train attachment this is what like a
three-year tour typically two or three
or two or for for most of these guys so
they've seen a bunch of different task
units come through and I remember very
mistake they say don't ever say that
again don't ever say that again Buckeyes
yeah and you you didn't take that as
like oh thank you for saying that I
appreciate it you actually were upset
because you knew that that's the kind of
thing that would make us cocky and now
we think we're awesome so we don't have
to train hard we don't actually have to
push ourselves hard which is then gonna
make sure that we get our that's going
to set us up for failure when it's time
to actually roll it on operations for
real and uh and so I I think those
things the harder that you're pushing
yourself a training the harder that
you're preparing the more discipline
that you have
um you know in those training procedures
it gives you the confidence to go and
execute well yeah yeah you can
definitely set those things up properly
where you can learn to flip that switch
you can learn to become a little bit
cocky in the just a moment before
execution
and it's something that I I and what I
remember telling you about it yo because
I told you about it at total archery
challenge right because here we are a
total archery challenge I'm shooting my
brand new bow which you know you got to
get used to a new bow right you got to
get used to it it's I got different cams
on it it's a little bit you know feels a
little bit different and so you're
getting used to the new bow and I this
was only like my
third time shooting it and which is
insane yeah like if if you know anything
about total archery challenge it's
freaking awesome uh it's it's an
incredible experience but it is uh I
mean you're making a the first the first
shot out of the pipe for us on day one
on the uh the course that we shot was
was 117 yards so I mean this is a that
is a ball it's like that's like a
thousand yard rifle uh shot yeah and
you're taking going out of the pipe and
you've only shot this boat yeah a couple
of times now look at what 20 yards yeah
and now look Dudley you know this this
bill is Bo is built by one of the
Premier guys in the world
so we're getting a high quality item but
still it takes reps and I'm not I'm you
know I've only been doing archery for
five years so I'm not like some stud at
this stuff
but I had just done this podcast uh with
echo on on the Underground talking about
and someone had asked like how do you
handle what do you do to get ready for
stroke and I talked to this whole thing
you got to prepare you gotta and then I
said and you know what I do at the
moment just before execution I get a
little bit cocky and what made me think
about that was like shoot head plates
you know back in the day you're going up
like I would I would never be the best
shot but I might be like fourth in the
platoon
you know depending on the Run maybe I'd
win one thing or two things but I wasn't
gonna be like there's always gonna be a
guy that's just freaking awesome shot
right
but you know when I was time to walk up
this calling it competition I just
almost called it competition but it is
you're like competing like okay you and
me life and I at that moment I'd be like
cool I'm gonna kick your ass like a life
sucks like I'm gonna and that would just
be enough to be like just it's enough to
let go of the the of the pressure and
just be like I got this so we're at
total archery Challenge and I had this
in my head the whole time so every time
and these are freaking
stupid shots 100 yards freaking 70 what
was that 73 yard freaking White Rabbit
like and you and me both hit that bad
boy but
like I'm walking up to the line like
watch this like step aside and
it really did help there's the best I've
ever shot attack and it's the least
prepared I've been the lead it was the
least prepared I've been at Tac and the
and the best I've ever shot and it's
because I consciously now was telling
myself watch this oh you got this I'm
gonna smoke this thing life's gonna look
like an idiot when I get done with this
like what do you got Dudley like just
all this and you know what you know you
can see Dudley do that too you can see
Dudley has a little switch that flips
where someone will talk to him and
all of a sudden he looks like a little
bit different and you're like oh he's
gonna murder this target
I had a guy that was a I was on a ship
with and you know I was a radio man this
guy working the radio man radio room and
you know one we're talking because I'm
building relationships I'm talking he's
like yeah you know I played I played
double a ball or Triple A ball which
one's higher he was like just underneath
the major leagues in baseball
I forget which one is Triple A Double A
but he was just underneath the major
leagues in baseball and you know in the
Navy I don't know if it's like this in
Marine Corps but in the Navy every just
about every dude could have been you
know a contender you know could have
been a professional could have been you
know had scholarships but blah blah blah
blah so I'm figuring he's one of these
guys and he's like yeah you know he's
like I'm trying I'm gonna try again when
I get back I'm gonna try and make
another run at it he's like do you can
you catch for me and I was like well I
was like dude I suck at baseball but you
know I got a buddy as a matter of fact
it's the same buddy I was talking about
earlier the visor wear I was like hey
one of my buddies is a sick athlete and
I'm sure he'd do it and
so he goes yeah meet me up and I I hook
them up and he the guy traveled with a
catcher's mitt just so he could pitch
because he's a pitcher
and so I walk up with my buddy because
this guy's gonna meet him on the flight
deck and Pitch to him
and dude this guy's a kind of a dorky
looking radio man like stuck inside all
day pale white like
and he comes walking out he's got like a
baseball hat on and the fat dip in and
he looked like a totally different
person and I was like oh this dude's
this dude's a badass and sure enough
like I couldn't have caught the pitches
that he was throwing he's just ripping
those things at 90 miles an hour
so that little bit of
confidence
at the moment of execution is is a
powerful thing and it lets you get into
the mode of I think it lets you let go
of worry right because you're like oh
what if I blow this shot again freaking
life's gonna make fun of me and Dudley's
gonna think I'm an idiot and the
freaking photographers here like all
that stuff could be going through your
head or you just be like
are you filming because you're going to
want to catch this
here's a free lesson
yeah so that's a that's a good thing and
it doesn't just work for you yeah you
let you let me in on that little secret
uh right after you made this ridiculous
shot I think it was like it was like a
it was like an 84-yard bomb it was like
two trees and I think I just shellacked
one of the trees and uh because
everyone's like talking smack over my
shoulder because that definitely gets in
your head and you you got up there and
there was smack talk coming at you too
and you just you just slid it right in
there freaking nail the Target and I was
like that was a freaking money shot and
you you said I gotta let you in all the
stick and as I thought about that I'm
like that's that's a really powerful
thing because it really there there is
something and when you're when you're
second guessing yourself at the moment
of execution it does not help you at all
um terrible second guessing yourself
about whether or not you're fully
prepared and in the weeks and months up
up to something sure that's great push
yourself positive but in that moment of
execution to be able to clear your mind
and ask you with confidence I think it's
a really powerful tactic to the employee
and and for instance right now I could
be like yo I shot so good at tack I you
know I'm freaking good to go that's the
that's the disease of Victory right
that's like oh I'm good to go that
that's what I I will not do that I'm
gonna shoot even harder than I ever have
because these are sort of like my mom's
getting ready for September right now
I could easily go oh you know I'm
freaking kind of dialed this year you
know what I mean it'd be so easy to do
that but that then what will the results
be the results will be freaking a
disaster on game day so don't you gotta
once you switch that on when you're done
cool go back to just like we go on an
operation we're confident going out
there maybe even just borderline a
little bit cocky we get back what do we
do what can we do better what mistakes
do we make how can we improve so you got
to flip that switch a little bit of a
little bit of confidence up the
confidence a little bit as soon as you
get done go right back to where you were
humble start working uh
I think this is the last thing I want to
talk about when it comes to when it
comes to culture
and that is what I call material items
and we've talked about it a little bit
already these are like these are the
t-shirts these are the patches these are
the the the uniforms the material things
that
represent the culture and unify the
culture and I got another uh piece in
here from hackworth
and you know that's a part of it's a
part of about face that I haven't talked
about too much and this is when when
hackworth is in Vietnam he stood up an
element that was called the Tigers and
there's a bunch of controversy about
them they ended up with like War crime
charges after he left I haven't gone
into much detail my bottom but they're a
huge part just it's just one of the many
parts of about face that there's you
know 850 pages in there and I just
haven't covered it all in the podcast
but in in one of those things he talks
about
this uh this he was also very fond of
snipers
which is where I got all my fondness for
snipers so he he had set up a sniper
program in one of these battalions he
says this as with Night Hunter the
daytime sniper program was tremendously
successful the result of it all was that
the snipers like the Tigers before them
in the one 327 became my pets
I called them my little babies and
showered them with attention and
recognition for their contribution to
the battalion's efforts
I even gave them their own uniforms
camouflage tiger stripe with the Added
Touch of black Berets with a red rocondo
patch sewed on
so what are you doing why is hack worth
doing this why didn't Leif and his
little arguments to me with Seth when
they'd go why didn't they pull it see
they if I give them about face they'd be
like hey Jocko Aqua said patch is good
to go I would have been like you know
good point let's do it but you know they
didn't quite get there but that's the
thing and you know we also write about
hey it's not about what you hang on your
wall it's not about the PowerPoint that
you make
but you have to remember that these
material things
are not just words they're par they can
become part of your culture they they
can absolutely become part part of your
culture so things like
t-shirts things like baseball hats
things like patches
things like coins I mean there's people
that are obsessive with coins or with
patches or with baseball hats or
t-shirts all these things
and you can make them mean something you
really can my uh kid my son went to a
camp
it doesn't exist anymore unfortunately
because it was freaking outstanding J
rob intensive wrestling camps
and
at J rob
you would the whole
goal is to get this shirt
get a t-shirt a freaking t-shirt that
says I did it that's what it says you
get a t-shirt that says I did it you're
not guaranteed that t-shirt they have
they grade you the whole time there's
demerit you get you have to you can't
miss so so-and-so stuff like it's it's
hard to get the shirt I don't know what
the percentage is but it's you're not
guaranteed the shirt at all
my kid had a like a badly sprained ankle
going there and it didn't get any better
while he's wrestling three times a day
and doing conditioning so the last thing
you have to do to get the shirt was you
have to do a 12 mile run
and there's no time limit but you just
got to complete it and so I was talking
to him and his ankle's been hurting the
whole time and he's been taping it up
and everything and trying to push
through and now he's got to do a 12 mile
run on a bum ankle
and
I'm talking to him at night and I said
you know how are you doing
and he said oh I'm doing okay and I said
How's your ankle and he says oh it's
hurt bad and I said what are you gonna
do and he said I'm going to tape it up
so it can't move and I'm gonna do that
run
and sure enough he went out there you
know whatever and knocked out that 12
miles on on that on that bad bad uh leg
why
because he wanted that t-shirt
he wanted that t-shirt
and so what are you doing what's your
culture what do you what are you doing
inside your own State I mean think about
getting a trident
like it may not seem like a big deal you
know but when you were young
man like that's a big deal you get your
Trident
the eagle globe and anchor oh yeah
what's up with that dude yeah so all
through boot camp you can't wear the
Marine Corps insignia on your uniform
outside of the one that's stitched on
the cover
um and on graduation day of boot camp
your drill instructor hands you your
first eagle globe and anchor that you
can wear on your uniform and it's a big
deal do they give that after The
Crucible now I believe so I think
they've changed it up since because I've
seen a bunch of Muddy dudes with tears
in their eyes
I'm not opposed to that yeah I The
Crucible I think was a week or two
before you you graduate boot camp so
it's right there at the end of the uh
line of training so I you know that that
seems appropriate to me too plus the the
level of like
just in the game you are after The
Crucible too I can definitely see that
yeah well this is like that's that's the
call right yeah you get them you got
them freaking broken down you got them
uh fatigued sleep deprivation
emotionally freaking at their lowest and
then you roll in with that EGA and a
hand salute you bro yeah you're ready to
rock and roll USMC Semper Fi I I will
say that at graduation when I got mine
uh it was pretty powerful because you've
got your platoon with you you've got the
people in the stands you've got family
there and stuff and it's it's pretty
powerful that way too I will say yeah
yeah pretty legit so what are you doing
are you making patches last babbling's
over there making freaking patches for
tasking the Bruiser heck yeah I mean I
think if it it means something right if
they just handed you a new Global anchor
it wouldn't really mean anything but you
know you actually hey man you went
through the the toughest boot camp you
know of any U.S military service uh I
think that's pretty generally widely
accepted that Marine Corps boot camp is
uh sets the standard there so it means
something man you go through buds you
know and then sqt graduate get your your
tried I mean it took you a year and a
half to get that thing you know uh at
with a 70 80 attrition rate like it
means something and I think that uh when
you create something around that it's
part of that unique identity it's part
of that unique culture it gives you some
idea of like Hey we're different we're
separate I think that's what it was for
us
um for the patches really that's why we
violated your order there's not too many
direct orders I've gotten from Jocko uh
ever uh and they're certainly not not uh
I don't I don't recall any other time
where I've directly violated the word
that you told me but when Seth and I
came up you know with uh this idea of
like hey we should get some batches made
you know when I threw it out there to
him as an idea I didn't actually know
what he was going to say I thought he
might like do Joker said no but we can't
do it you know and and it's and he was
like dude we gotta freaking do it and
and we did it because you know if I
think about I never really I didn't
really give it a lot of thought at the
time about a dissect why that was
important to us but it was important to
us because we knew that this was a
unique and historic unit that we were a
part of we wanted to have that identity
we wanted to actually go have some
impact on the battlefield you know and I
felt like a unit patch would be really
important to that so
um I think you know when you're thinking
about building the culture of your team
you know what are those things that you
can do we've seen some of our clients
you know where they they've got stickers
for their hard hats you know that
they're uh and you got to earn that
extreme ownership sticker you got to
earn that cover Move sticker you know
when when you actually do something that
sets a standard it means something and
you get recognized in front of your
peers and and put something like that on
your uniform I think that gives that
just creates part of that culture so
that people know this is what the
standard is this is what good looks like
I want aspire to actually get that and
and uh I think it's it's a very powerful
thing I don't remember the exact quote
but
Napoleon
but he said something along the lines of
it's amazing what a man will do for a
worthless piece of cloth when he's
talking about a ribbon that's being
awarded to you for your Valor on the
battle you went and put your life on the
line or even maybe even gave your life
and you're getting recognized with this
kind of worthless piece of cloth it
actually costs nothing uh or you know
and yet this is the public recognition
of hey here's what I did to actually
earn that thing I want to earn that
thing I want to actually be special I
want to be unique I think there's
something really powerful in them yeah
and and you can this is the cool thing
you can create this you can create these
kind of things inside your organization
and all these things that we're talking
about
will help you create a culture a strong
culture it will help Define Who You Are
what you do and how you do it
and if you have a strong culture it is
one of the most powerful things that you
can have inside an organization
so build it
and protect it
best culture
uh
speaking of building
we're trying to build up right we're
trying to get stronger always always
trying to get stronger if you need to
get stronger you're going to need the
right fuel we recommend use choco fuel
get yourself some Mulk get yourself some
energy drink what do you what flavor you
got over their life I got uh I got a
little sour apple sniper right now
represented for JP Danelle that's the um
yeah sour apple I'm on the Tactical tea
train which
Carrie has entered the train you're on
board the train I'm on board the train
what happened so I've been going through
kind of Cycles I was on the Orange train
yeah for a long time and then I got on
the pink Mist train yeah I can see that
yeah and now the wave is the the 50 50
tactical
underrated under recognized under
recognized for sure yeah and it's
because
we made the flavors better and like I
love the old one but some people didn't
love the old one and maybe they shied
away from it but if you like if you like
that Arnold Palmer and let's face it bro
let's face it on Arnold Palmer
a good Arnold summertime too it's
summertime I think that might be playing
into it it's July yeah it's July we're
going summer time Arnold Palmer salute
to Arnold Palmer salute he was like hey
give me some tea put some lemonade in it
that's what we're doing so good call but
I said yeah that's that's if I'm out
when I'm drinking when I'm drinking
that's what I'm drinking like if leif's
like hey let's go get crazy tonight I'm
like cool I have an Arnold Palmer at the
bar right tastes freaking good man
actually what you normally order is uh
Iced Tea unsweetened nice tea with a
shot of it just a shot just a shot shot
of lemonade I get it I gotta say though
man the the 50 50 tackle is tasty
obviously Citrus psycho is my flavor and
that's my go-to but I love to mix it up
and uh it's uh that's that is a close
second there I usually rotate between
that fit the 50 50 tactical Citrus
psycho and uh like pink pink Mist yeah
and the the Dax Savage is always these
are all good man and this nice like you
could probably figure out a rotation
like working out where you're like look
technically technically tactical tea
pink Mist tactical tackle tea tactical
tea Citrus psycho like you can figure
out a good rotation where you're just in
Texas it's been freaking 100 degrees so
like the the ice cold 50 50 tackle is
good I'll tell you what else is good ice
cold is the Tropic Thunder
it's just freaking tasty yeah so anyways
jockoffuel.com get yourself some Mulk
some rtds
God those things are good and they're
just look honestly they're a little too
convenient right they're a little too
convenient because you got that RTD and
you know you get 30 grams of protein in
14 seconds just get jacked you're just
let's go
there's a little bit when you have to
work for it a little bit when you got to
get the Shaker you know when you're
doing that whole gig maybe you but when
you got that 30 30 grams out of cap
twist boom It's Going Down the Hatch
it's awesome but it actually I mean man
if I've been tracking the macros and
it's unless you're just gonna eat
freaking ground turkey and bison all the
time like it's it's hard to hit that you
know it's hard to hit that freaking 200
grams of protein uh and those rtds are
awesome for that just Hammer one down
post Jiu Jitsu roll or coming out of the
uh it almost the CrossFit gym it almost
feels like cheating you know but because
it's supposed to be harder to get
protein yeah that's true right that's
true meat mixing up the milkshake it
almost feels like it should be harder
it's weird have you ever done because
this has sort of become sort of a
protocol for me get done like on a
Saturday Sunday Wake Up Lift Run come to
jiu jitsu go on the way to jiu jitsu
which I know is tactically cheating kind
of maybe a little bit
get their train get done Mulk cookie
Mulk there's 44 grams of protein done
like we're done and you know what's
interesting about that is then you're
you feel full you don't feel and this is
after a workout run and then Jiu Jitsu
like this is a lot of energy expended so
you're gonna be hungry but you go and
get that much protein in you and you're
like oh I'm good to go which means the
afternoon you're not like
just food coma from a freaking slab of
meat in a bun whatever you know what I
mean that'll put you down you'll be like
yo you're like Sunday after Saturday
afternoon Sunday afternoon you got
podcast to prep and you're like looking
at the freaking computer and it started
like the eyes are getting heavy because
you just ate whatever a pound and a half
of freaking meat no you're feeling
you're just like light stomach boom 44
grams of protein good to go that's
that's my recommendation
it's my recommendation out there uh yeah
Dr fuel.com go get it we got everything
that you need we got joint Warfare super
Krill vitamin D3 Cold War dude time War
time War I got being out on the road
Jocko live got a lot of reports on time
War just that
that redirection of life that being on
step that I feel good now which is a
which is a very broad statement to make
and I can attest to it like oh I feel
good now that's what I feel like so
check it out we got it for you there uh
Wawa you can get it at Vitamin Shop GNC
we're in the military commissaries
I was telling some military folks the
other day just just grab one we're on
we're going in the exchanges right now
like the NEX which is a big deal because
I know all you freaking 24 year old
Marines you're not shopping at the
commissary all you 18 year old Soldiers
you're not going to the commissary
that's too much planning but you're
definitely stopping by The Exchange that
you you know 21 year old sailor coming
back from a a three-week exercise you're
not going to the commissary that's like
a big deal but you're going to the NEX
so we're in there
um AAFES Hannaford Dash doors Maryland
wake Fern ShopRite HEB how we
representing representing strong in HEB
Tejas Good Times yeah like uh end caps
and stuff like it's on so the reason
it's on the reason that we're we're able
to do that in HEB is because you all
down there in Tejas are just getting
after it so appreciate it same thing
with Meyer up in the midwest same thing
like you guys are crushing it so that's
a huge deal Harris Teeter another one
appreciate it Lifetime Fitness Shields
and and by the way small gyms out there
Jiu Jitsu gyms CrossFit gyms
if you want to
if you want your people to get better
and give them every Advantage you can
email jfsales jockofuel.com and we can
we can hook you up you can start to sell
stuff inside your store that's there you
go jockofuel.com check it out that's
actually uh both still a jiu jitsu our
Jiu Jitsu gym and well as CrossFit
second wave our cross pajamas they got
it they get all the Jocko products right
there so you get done pre pre-workout
get uh jump on the train smoke train
post workout it's awesome so we got this
is this is Leif Babin protocol you got
CrossFit second wave which is in
Dripping Springs Texas right that's
that's where you're training your
physical fitness and then you've got
stoic Jiu Jitsu which by the way we just
did a podcast with Ryan holiday I I
didn't even mention stuff I talked to
him about it but it wasn't we weren't
recording
correct this was after the podcast or we
already wrapped it up so stoic Jiu Jitsu
also in Dripping Springs is it in
Dripping Springs Dripping Springs so you
can you can train that Jiu Jitsu you can
train that CrossFit go get a Fran
together go get go get an Anna together
go get a Grace together go get one of
those workouts
go get it and and help yourself you know
life I know you've you've gone through
some like injuries for sure and you know
you and I have talked about that
and the attitude is when you hurt when
your back is hurt and you can't dead
lift
the idea isn't I can't deadlift the idea
is I have to get back to dead lifting
when you hurt your shoulder the idea
isn't oh I can't do shoulder presses the
idea is I need to get back to shoulder
get out the PVC
get I'm no stranger I was talking about
this reverse horn like I'll get out the
PVC all day oh I can't I can't do an
overhead press right now with any weight
because my shoulders tweaked cool
where's the PVC I'm gonna try and keep
that Mobility up and this is something
that I need to focus on right now
because my Mobility right now sucks
and so I've been trying to open that
game back up then it takes a while you
blow it off and I'm I'm the worst I have
the worst attitude I'm stretching bores
me it makes me mad I don't like it I'd
rather throw something hit something
choke something it's so far down on my
list of pleasure and life but it's what
I need to do
so that's what you got to do you got a
little issue work through it do what you
can and that's the cool thing about
CrossFit you can you can adapt to what's
happening oh you can't do a heavy
deadlift right now okay that's cool you
can do burpees instead or you can't do
an overhead press right now because your
shoulders tweaked that's okay dual one
arm snatch with the other arm that's
working so
that's what you got to do you got to
scale these things but the worst thing
you can do is get off the bus and stay
off the bus same thing with Jiu Jitsu
same thing with Jiu Jitsu you look
sometimes you got to get off the bus
right you go on I just did
it was
two weeks ago I was gone for like four
straight weeks off the bus like I didn't
train I was on the road I think I
trained the whole twice
and then I came back and it was like I
got back on a Friday night and I know
what I was staring at because Saturday
you know you know what's on Saturday so
I'm like okay I see the bus and there's
all kinds of reasons not to get it back
on because you know you haven't been
training and the guys are already and
you're freaking tired and you've been on
the road and all these excuses
to not get on the bus I'm gonna tell you
right now get on the freaking bus get
back on the bus same thing with your
whole workout program oh you couldn't do
something because you were tired you
heard you were sick you were hurt cool
get back on the bus dude my back's
tweaked right now today I posted dealing
with it I'm sure people have no idea
what I'm talking about but you know what
I did it freaking did what I could I
couldn't do my normal workout but I went
in there and did what I could that's
what I'm gonna do and it's not like I've
got some major back you got a freaking
little tweak I'm not gonna tweak it
worse but I'm I'm not gonna sit around
and just let it freeze up and lock up
and let let the let the the clock keep
ticking so that's what we're doing what
do you got and nobody cares no nobody
cares if you've not been on the bus
nobody noticed yeah nobody even it's you
in your brain thinking somebody cares
about you not being on the bus yeah
nobody even noticed yeah yeah there's
two ego things going on number one oh
now I'm gonna get Tapped Out by freaking
Fred because he's been I've been gone
that's part of your ego the other part
of your ego is do you think Fred cares
you think that Fred's been watching him
plotting on you he doesn't care Fred's
worried about Fred I'm worried about you
so get back on the bus people
that you know you mentioned me having a
bunch of injuries and I think that's the
the worst thing that you can do is is
the not not train I mean I think you
know the do what you can like you're
just talking about with with Peter t on
on the podcast uh that he was on with
you I think that's you got to do what
you can and that's that's been something
that's game changer for me
um and it gets me back in the gym if I
gotta scale it or I got to do something
different in the workout like cool no no
big deal
um I gotta tell you man too speaking of
Jocko fuel products though if if I'm you
know if I'm hitting that krill oil you
know uh or the joint Warfare stuff that
makes a massive difference I've noticed
that so much when I'm off of it and uh
it is something that just it enables me
to keep going to get after it and and
just to stay on the path that's that's
been a huge a huge one yeah those those
products you can those are some of our
most highly subscribed actually joint
Warfare is our most subscribed product
so people that just are gonna be they're
on that they're on that train there's a
reason for it it's exactly what you said
when you go off of it you feel it so
get on the bus get on Jocko fuel let's
go rock and roll also originusa.com
we're making stuff in America and this
is it was very interesting talking to
Ryan holiday about this and what
happened with American Apparel and you
know he understood so clearly the idea
of green washing have you know what
green washing is so green washing is hey
we have we have a company we make shirts
and we give one percent of our profit or
three percent of our profit to
environmental causes because we love the
environment
and you go oh wow that's really nice
where do you make your shirts and
they're like oh we make them in China we
make them in Bangladesh wherever we're
in a place where there's no
Environmental Protection whatsoever
that's what they're doing so they they
destroy the environment and then throw a
little one percent Band-Aid on it it's
called green washing it's lies that's
what it is and we're not doing that in
origin USA and they do the same thing
with their workers I read some freaking
little little uh little uh Catalog
online catalog and it was like and our
and our workers earn a fair wage
according to who according to mount
saintung is that what we're doing is
that who is according to you know a fair
wage you're liars and then you
and you call and you try and make it
sound like you're you're you're you're
doing the right thing you're not you're
full of if you really truly this is
the facts if they really truly wanted to
do the right thing if they really truly
care about the environment if they
really truly cared about people and
workers they would not manufacture that
stuff overseas period end of story
period end of story they would not do it
they don't give a and they try and
make like they do they're Liars we
actually care about workers we care
about America we care about the security
and National Security in this country
and we care about the environment that's
why we make it 100 here in America so go
to originusa.com and get
workout gear get Jiu Jitsu gear get hunt
gear get blue jeans get rash guards
t-shirts boots get what you need but get
it from a place that is actually backing
up and doing what we talk about not
throwing one percent and and and virtue
signaling that how great we are because
they're full of
so that's originusa.com go it's National
Security by the way
it's National Security
you buy a pair of jeans you want to help
you oh you want to protect Freedom cool
go buy a pair of jeans
that's not that is not a stretch that is
a fact
you are helping the National Security of
this country you're helping the freedom
of this country you're helping people
not be in slavery around the world
so originusa.com go get some also if you
want to represent on the path go to
jockostore.com get yourself some
discipline equals Freedom gear
um check out that shirt Locker
subscription we got a new shirt every
month coming out with different layers
portrayed by Echo Charles the shirt
Locker those shirt Locker shirts are
legit man so those are awesome and
there's a little cultural activity going
on there right there's a cultural
activity when I was at joggle live and I
looked out and just see Sherlock or
shirts people representing on the path
that's what we're doing
and you know you know you can't
have that discipline equals Freedom
T-shirt and miss a workout you know you
can't do it because it's a little peer
pressure from us
from all of us we're in the game get in
the game jocostore.com go get it is this
a material item it's a material item 100
reinforce the culture reinforce the
culture bond with your teammates what
team are you on we're on the get after a
team Deathcore yes we're on the deaf
core team what team are you on by the
way are you on the slack team is that
the team you're on because we're over
here on the Deathcore team
get in the game
uh subscribe to the podcast uh subscribe
to Jocko underground Jocko
underground.com subscribe to the YouTube
we got Echelon front YouTube channel
we've got Jocko podcast YouTube channel
we got Jocko fuel YouTube channel we got
origin USA YouTube channel all different
stuff you wanna know what's going on
inside of these various worlds check
them out flipsidecanvas.com Dakota Meyer
he's making cool stuff to hang on your
wall he's making material items to hang
on you all to keep you on the freaking
path
we got a bunch of books you know them
all if you need books get them and get
those kid books get the books for the
kids I signed so many kids books at
Jocko live and there was probably
I don't know maybe a total of 20 toward
your kids ton of warrior kids that
showed up
ask questions freaking legit outstanding
you can tell that these kids are going
to do better in life because they are on
the warrior kid path 100 I guarantee it
I guarantee it
so get those books for your kids
hackworth we read a little extreme
ownership today dichotomy leadership you
know the books go get them Echelon front
we have a leadership consultancy we
solve problems through leadership that's
what we do we go inside your
organization we can help you build build
culture we can help align your
leadership we can help solve whatever
problems you have hey what am I talking
about what do you mean Joker you can
solve whatever problems we can we have
how can you do that we can do that
through leadership because whatever
problems you have it's a leadership
problem
so go to ashlandfront.com if you need
our help
in whatever organization you're in and
whatever problems you're having also we
have Live Events next one uh
we have the muster in Dallas but it's
sold out yes we just posted it's sold
out so Dallas muster next one's gonna be
in San Diego right Diego we're coming
back
to the to Jocko's AO my area of
operations if you want to come to one of
those musters
uh check it out echelonfront.com we also
have the FTX
JP's running a bunch of those back to
back down and down in Texas we have
Battlefield coming up I think it's sold
out you can check there might be a
couple spots left for a Little Bighorn
checking out that Battlefield
a lot of lessons learned there a lot of
lessons learned and then also we have
the women's assembly we got Jamie
Cochran the CEO of echelon front she is
running a women's assembly in September
September 14th through 16th in Phoenix
Arizona and if you didn't hear her on
the podcast one when she initially said
she wanted to do this
I was like negative because the the
principles are the same but what I
realized I looked at it from a jiu jitsu
perspective and there have been many
many many women over the years that
didn't want to get on they they didn't
connect with what that Jiu Jitsu thing
was they didn't want to get on the
freaking mats with Carrie Helton or
Jocko or echo or Leif that look like I
don't know what's going on but I don't
think that looks that's not that's not
for me but that women's class also they
go okay I see that I see what's going on
oh there's something you can learn
techniques okay and then once they come
in the women's class then they start to
understand Jiu Jitsu it opens the door
next thing you know they're choking
Carrie Hilton yes sir that's what's
going down so same thing here an
opportunity to check these things out
from Jamie Cochran's perspective uh
she's an outstanding leader across the
board in her own right so you can go
learn from her and some of the other
women on the echelon front team
we also have an online training academy
extreme ownership.com
these are skills leadership is a skill
it may not seem like it and if you're it
may not seem like it just like it may
not seem like fighting is a skill like
you think oh I can just when I see red
no one can beat me no they can beat you
matter of fact 140 pound dude that knows
jujitsu can beat you but I'm 210 pounds
yep then you'll get beat you'll get
choked out
these are skills leadership is a skill
and it's a skill that you use in
everything that you do
it's a skill that you use even if you're
the lowest ranking person in your
organization you're still in a
leadership position because you have to
interact with your peers and you have to
lead your boss
and even if you're the lowest ranking
person in your organization guess what
you still have
a girlfriend a boyfriend
a wife a husband a couple kids
uh
Little League team
the parent Teachers Association you're
interacting with other people that's
what you're doing
and it is an actual skill to do that
and if you don't have these skills you
don't know what you're doing and you're
gonna get choked out by a 140 pound
individual
don't let it happen
we've got two new courses on there what
are they the read back and the debrief
with you and Carlos Mendez okay there
you go two new courses and listen I said
this on the last one at a minimum at a
minimum please
go and take the free courses that we've
got on there go and take the extreme
ownership framework go and take that
course so you can understand this is
going to help in everything that you do
in everything that you do this is like
I'm gonna give you six thousand dollars
cash right now what if I was like hey
Carrie is this gonna help you if I give
you six thousand dollars cash yes life
can I give you six thousand dollars cash
is that gonna be helpful to you break it
on is that gonna help some part of your
life
you go and take this free course just
take six thousand dollars cash put it in
your pocket because that's what it's
like you also you're gonna get help
you're gonna be able to help with the
things that you do your life is going to
get a little bit better
it might even get a lot better there's
people that have there's people that
when they uh when they when they see
extreme ownership and they actually
comprehend it there's people that it
doesn't just change their life a little
bit it transforms their existence I just
met 30 people like that
during the Live Events 30 people that
came up to me and in 28 seconds said
that this information
transformed their life transformed the
way that they are living their life they
got promoted they kept their marriage
together they got a better relationship
with their kid on and on and on and on
so at a minimum just go take those free
classes they're on there please I'm
giving it to you please take it don't
want anything else from you just go take
that because it's gonna make your life
better
extreme ownership.com go check it out I
think one thing I love so much about
extreme ownership Academy you know these
online courses they're interactive you
know and they dive so deep into these
principles people you know loved extreme
ownership and these Concepts that are in
there and yet we break down each chapter
you know with a course there and all the
the other courses that come out the
debrief course you know and and the
relationships of course all these other
courses that that uh the read back of
course that we've released it's breaking
down some small detail that got
mentioned in the book but really
expanded on that and going deep and then
talking about how it applies in a real
world scenario and we do those those uh
role plays where we talk about what to
do and what not to do which is sometimes
the most helpful thing you know to learn
so I think those those courses are uh uh
I have I have been deeply impressed by
the amount of information that can be
conveyed and how you can actually test
someone's knowledge about whether or not
they they understand it you know through
these courses so definitely it is a
massive Resource as you've said it's
probably the best secret we have at
Echelon front that extreme ownership
Academy is this is something that can
absolutely change the game for you to
help you understand these principles and
how to apply them in your life yeah
extreme ownership.com go check it out
that's all I'm saying and if you want to
help service members active and retired
you want to help their families you want
to help gold star families check out
Markley's mom mama Lee She's Got an
amazing charity organization
we know like everyone at this table
right now Carrie Leif myself we know
personally people that have gone through
Mama Lee's programs and it has
transformed their lives
so
if you want to help a veteran
go to America's Mighty Warriors dot org
and donate or get involved however you
can and also don't forget about Micah
Fink
he's up there with Heroes and horses.org
what's the latest report
I believe Micah did a flying backflip
off of a cliff Edge to spear a grizzly
in the back of the neck to save a couple
of children on the trail okay so this is
like a normal day for Micah Fink he's
just out there uh doing what he's doing
seriously he's up there taking our
veterans and First Responders up into
the Wilderness and they are reconnecting
with their souls
it's an incredibly powerful thing and
he's an incredible guy if you want to
help him out Heroes and horses dot org
and if you want to connect with us on
the interwebs
we're on there life is on Twitter at
leifbab and he's on the gram at real
life Batman he missed missed out huh you
blew it a little late a little late to
the game on the gram actually I think uh
I actually think that um
back in the day when uh when you or
vehemently get social media and uh
my wife Jenna and our now CEO Jamie
Cochran conspired to launch your to to
launch your your uh social media for you
in your in even though you're against it
I I think that there was one launch for
me at that time on the gram as well
which now no one knows the the login so
so I'm real late for that so you're at
real life Babin on the gram are you on
threads I'm not
okay
Carrie speaking of late to the game
Carrie with the underscore this is like
a this is like both you guys that's like
uh uh that's The Red Badge or The
Scarlet Letter right the real life real
life Batman that's Scarlet Letter
underscore Scarlet Letter
I'm over here talking I am because
guess what I got at Jocko willink that's
it you can't even mess with me you can't
mess with me I got it I was in the game
and I wasn't even in the game yet so
there you go how you like them Apple's
underscore
I'm officially putting out the word at
Carrie Hilton I'm coming for you so so
I'm not taking this from Jacob so do you
think at Leif Babin actually exists it
does yeah and you think you might have
it I mean if I got at Jocko willink you
must have got yeah I think it was
launched at the exact same time but
it was uh this is too difficult to
recover yeah uh are you on threads yes
okay so we got in the game are you are
you underscore
[Music]
it's it's connected to this I know so
you're connected to that underscore
that's got to be a bummer it is kind of
a bummer yeah yeah just always having to
throw that in there just eats it
constantly reminded so you're gonna try
and you coming at Carrie Hilton I am
do you reach out who do you how do you
do it uh the last time I just DM the guy
yeah did he respond nah because he he
hadn't been active in like you know
years on it or something so maybe he
just left it
just just squatting on your soul
keep that underscore bro it gives you
gives you character yeah sure no you
can't make it cool bro you can't all
right yeah if you want to connect with
us that's where we're at just just be
careful because as Leif pointed out I
used to be vehemently anti-social media
and I still kind of am
because I recognize that there is an
algorithm in there that's powerful
that's that the
smartest group of Engineers they could
assemble get together every day and
figure out how to make you spend more
time on that thing
that's what they want that's what
they're begging for that's they're
manipulating you
that's what they're doing so it works we
know that people get addicted to it we
don't want that to happen to you so just
be careful just be careful the algorithm
keep your uh watch your six because the
algorithm is sneaking up on you and
thanks to all the troops that are out
there in uniform right now holding the
line thank you for what you do to
protect us and the same goes to our
police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol Secret Service
and all you First Responders out there
thank you for holding the line here at
home
and to everyone else out there
just remember that
the way you act and what you do
is who you are
who you are is your culture your
personal culture
that's how you live your life
so
be someone you can trust
be a fighter
don't allow any slack
at all instead be a hardcore recondo
let that be your culture let that be who
you are let that be what you do and let
that be how you do it
November foxtrot Sierra
and until next time this is Leif and
Carrie and Jocko
out